Das war's für heute. Vielen Dank für's Zuhören und bis zum nächsten Mal!
Das war's für heute. Vielen Dank für's Zuhören.
Bless RNG
Fields Birthday Man
Woodface
Kokona
KappaPride
Dance Game
NotLikeThis
MonkaS
LUL
Resident Sleeper
Ayaya
Jebaited
LUL3D
GachiGasm
Poggers
LUL
Wie lang soll ich das jetzt noch machen?
Pains Champ
Wir fallen langsam keine mehr ein.
Wenn man sich mal genauer bildet, eigentlich waren das schon viel zu viele, die mir aus dem Kopf eingefallen sind, oder?
LUL
Toxy
Toxy 5 Monate, Dankeschön
LUL
Chat, ich seh euch kurz nicht, ich muss Chat refreshen.
Weil Twitch nicht aktualisiert.
Egal
Seit wann hat das Wendler-Video Punkte?
Hatte das schon immer Punkte?
Das ist mir noch nie aufgefallen.
Hat das Wendler-Video schon immer diese Punkte gehabt?
Hat das schon immer diese Punkte gehabt?
Das hat das schon immer diese Punkte gehabt?
Hab ich dir notificationen lassen.
Oh ist das erstmal installieren
Aquarium erholen pro gaming sebi ist am start der benutzer hat bereits zwei monat abonniert huge sub
Kokona
Corona sub
Dankeschön ist das schlimm wenn in einem bettel viel klipp musik drin ist ja das kommt drauf an also
Erstmal was für musik ist aber wie laut die ist ja also sprich wenn man
Selbst beim leise machen
Und beim drüber labern
Und bei der hintergrundmusik die ich an habe wenn man da immer noch neben deinem rumgeballert die musik hört in bettel vielen dann ist es
Zu laut
Oder aber ich mute den klipp das geht auch
also wenn es ein richtig ultra mega geiler klipp ist und
Da nehme ich den auch ohne sound
Übrigens guckt mal hier
Responses
Und ich weiß die ull nicht mehr einfach von hand verloren genau bumm bumm
Ja guck mal wie viele leute schon was eingeschickt haben das ist richtig
Massive leider ist nicht ganz so viel richtig gutes dabei guck mal
Das haben
Das kann man sich hier gar nicht angucken oder was
Das ist ja doof das kann ich das sehe ich bloß wenn ich eingeloggt bin okay ist ja eigentlich logisch
Da ich das nur sehen wenn ich eng glaube es haben
Es haben
67 leute jetzt insgesamt was eingeschickt
Beim letzten am ende vom letzten video waren es glaube 27 also es haben 40 leute jetzt noch was
Irgendwie ein noch mal irgendwie zusätzlich eingeschickt
Und ich 70 sind 70
Da ist leider viel miss dabei muss ich sagen manche sachen sind überhaupt nichts
Was man was man zeigen kann aber gut ich mein ich will jetzt da keiner von abhalten ich flame ja auch keiner für wenn die
Plays nicht so gut sind aber manche sachen sind halt auch wir haben 69 zuschauer
Und manche sachen sind halt nicht so tolle also wenn man mal eine rakete irgendwo hin trifft
Wenn es jetzt nicht gerade da über trickshot ist dann dann hat es jeder schon mal irgendwie öfters mal gehabt
Gehen da nur bettel viel treibende viel viel klips du kannst auch noch was anderes schicken du kannst auch bett company klips schicken oder
Hardline klips schicken oder meinetwegen auch wenn es dir gefällt bettel viel eins bettel viel fünf klips auch schicken
Patrick es gibt schon leute die haben merkwürdige sachen verlinkt
Aber ich mache das eh immer unter linux auf und konvertiere die videos dann also dann ist
Irgendeiner hat so ein komisches gatschi video geschickt
Ich glaube nach acht jahren beide haben wir fast alles gesehen jetzt kommen aber drauf an wie häufig das ganze ist
also wie gesagt einmal einmal mit einem
Apg den heli abgeschossen ist jetzt nix nix top play mäßiges übrigens
das war safe
Mich wird da nichts wundern
Es gab letztens ein fehler bei microsoft im im dings hier da
in der virus and threat protection
Von windows gab es vor zwei tagen fehler und zwar da ist der windows defender hier
Das da
Wenn aus die fahnen oder wirken so und der fehler war
Das
Moment wo wo ist er nicht
genau
Der fehler war wenn es eine datei gibt die zwei die zwei punkte
Die zwei punkte vor der extension hatte dann ist der windows defender gekrasht ich weiß ja nicht was bei microsoft los ist
Dass so ein elementarer bestandteil von windows probleme mit doppelpunkten in der teilnahme hat wieder wenn aus die fände aber
Microsoft hat das geschafft
Es ist anatomisch unmöglich den eigenen hinterkopf abzulegnen ja der eichler das ist richtig
Aber acht monate hat er abonniert dankeschön huge sub hi iq
Angeblich ist es ja auch nicht möglich dass man seinen ellenburg ablecken kann aber da habe ich schon leute gesehen die können das
Der eichler es ist auch noch unmöglich glaube ich für die meisten leute andere andere sachen abzulegnen wenn ich gerade den namen seh
Es funktioniert glaube ich auch nicht zumindest microsoft hat es mal wieder richtig verkackt
So und also sprich wenn ein virus jetzt bei euch sich auf dem rechner breit machen wollte hätte der einfach in
der teilnahme gebraucht mit doppelpunkten
Einnahmen gebraucht mit doppelpunkten doppelpunkten easy mit aus die fände kaputt
Was auch immer sich microsoft dabei gedacht hat aber angeblich ist das ganze gefixt und ich hatte auch keine probleme mehr
Ja das weiß ich noch ja das weiß ich noch
Damals war pc zwar auch schon was der raise aber die meisten leute haben es noch nicht gecheckt ist sie punktpunkt virus punkt exe exakt
Und dann und dann war es weg
its af
punkt its
punkt punkt af
punkt exe
Ja der titel ist heute übrigens
Ist heute übrigens programm wir müssen ein bisschen z plus plus machen
Nicht wahnsinnig wichtig ist was unbedingt fertig werden muss
Was das immer für einen geflame aber ein den kommens auch ja
Tk. Scoot live
Huge sup danke schön
Ich liebe z plus plus oh je
Monka es da reich er monka monka giga es
Hyper Monka es
Wie kann man z plus plus mögen
Pains Tramp
näher
Pains Tramp näher zumindest
Ich wollte gerade noch irgendwas anderes erzählen bevor wir anfangen mal gucken ob ich mal ob ich mein linux immer updaten muss
Passt
Irgendwas ich wollte noch etwas anderes erzählen bevor wir anfangen und zwar
Ja und zwar ich habe ich habe ein bisschen was gebastelt und
Deswegen bin ich aber drauf gekommen dass z plus plus so krass sagt
Und zwar ich zeige euch mal was ich am start habe
Wir werden heute nämlich ein bisschen
C plus plus microcontroller zeug machen ich habe was gebastelt
Und zwar für meine tür gegensprechanlage eigentlich was total simples aber sehr praktisches
Was schreibt der patrick mein kuss dein kusen hat ja letztens ja ja ja in den diskord gepostet wann kommt das btt
Kann ich machen ja eigentlich brauchen wir das ja
Ich brauche an franka franka faces z link
Dazu dann mache ich das rein
Ja ja ja
Also ich zeige euch mal was zum beispiel warum man c++ nicht mögen kann bevor wir jetzt mit c++ anfangen
Zum beispiel sowas weil sie kann oft wird er ist es ne ne kein neues mikrofon immer noch das gleiche mikrofon
of whatever
8,5% sind die das Wahnsinns
was ist mit denen los kann das sein dass das stream dass das stream jetzt quasi seit ich
und bin geruckelt hat oder vielleicht hat das wie man ich geruckelt weil ich nicht genug
bildwechsel drin hat jetzt scheint es auch wieder zu gehen anzeige es raus ja ich ich
kann es ja zum teil verstehen jetzt wo alle daheim sind das problem ist aber gerade bei
voter faun und auch bei unity media bei telekom ein bisschen weniger aber gerade bei unity
media und voter faun ist ja das problem dass die normalerweise wenn die leute halt nicht
daheim sitzen ganzen tag online sind schon an der grenze sind das hat bestimmt was mit
c++ zu tun ja ich aber davon aus
bin gerade reingejohnt woher kommt der has mit c++ und musstest du was damit machen
ja also ich mache ab und zu immer mal was mit c++ ich finde jedes mal scheiße zum beispiel
eine sache ich habe gerade auf twitter gepostet wenn voter von sich jetzt hoffentlich wieder
eingekriegt hat wenn nicht sagt mir bescheid dann warte kurz solche sachen hier ich mein
was gibt sich das c++ standardgremium bevor sie irgendwelche standards beschließen dass
solche sachen hier legit empfohlen werden zu machen oder dass das nicht nur zu sagen
die einzige möglichkeit ist sowas zu machen also was mich da ja schon mal hardcore triggert
bei c++ nur bei diesem kleinen ausschnitt ist erstens ist c++ die einzige sprache auf
der welt die ich kenne die um was zu löschen erase verwendet alle anderen sank delete remove
ruby hat beispielsweise noch optional drop aber erase beim besten habe ich noch nie gehört
der tribulon ist sechs monat am start
dankeschön für den sub
subscriber
äh tribulon 3 hat mir jetzt auch einen bio dynamics kopfhörer zugelegt hatte mir da
dein mx 300 video von 2012 nochmal angeschaut ja das witzigste witzige daran ist ja dass
ich genau dieses dieses headset von 2012 immer noch aufhabe und wunderbar super funktioniert
ja
welche sprache magst du am liebsten c sharp und ruby ruby leider nicht mehr so angesagt
also sollte solche sachen überhaupt da drin sind ist schon mal ist schon mal hängen geblieben
was ich viel was ich noch noch viel schlimmer finde ist das was ich da vor deswegen ist
bei auch der titel für den stream eingefallen heute festgestellt ist wenn ich ein element
in einem vector löschen muss in c++ an einem index da kann ich nicht etwa sagen vector
remove ii nein ich muss sagen vector beginn plus ii erase wo ich mir auch an den monsterts
einer fertig das ausgedacht es gibt noch so viele andere sachen es sind wieder plus zwei
sachen die mir heute eingefallen sind zumindest ähm was ist deine go to native sprache näher
wenn es microcontroller zeug ist bleibt mir nichts viel anderes übrig als ähm so im
heimbereich hobbybereich arduino c c++ oder auch auf den ganzen esp dingern ist es entweder
die offizielle idf mit reinem c oder halt arduino mit c++ ähm ansonsten ansonsten wenn es einfach
nur binaries sein müssen die überall laufen dann meinetwegen auch go wobei ich auch nicht
angenehm empfinde rast ist ganz nice allerdings ist rast im gegensatz zu c++ ist rast eklig
zu lernen aber logisch im gegensatz zu c++ c++ ist c++ ist nicht ich wollte sagen einfach
zu lernen ein c++ ist alles andere als einfach zu lernen aber c++ ist einfach einfach anzufangen
ist in c++ einfach weil du kannst in c++ alles irgendwie irgendwie zusammen copy pasten
selbst wenn du gar keine ahnung hast rast meckert dich der checker der borrow checker
und das zeug meckert dich in rast instant in instant voll das heißt im endeffekt ist
rast ziemlich nervig zu lernen aber eigentlich logisch so und äh play rast moment die programmier
sprache genau ähm aber rast an sich eine super sprache ansonsten muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen
wenn ich die auswahl habe würde ich tatsächlich immer noch äh ganz so ganz kleine sachen
was ich kriege gerade komische messages auf dem handy äh nicht das was ihr denkt so und
kleinkram würde ich wahrscheinlich immer noch in c machen aber rast ist gut rast ist
rast ist nice also ich würde gerne mehr mit rast machen meine äh kameraüberwachungssoftware
die mir auch hier ein bisschen im stream gebastelt haben und die jetzt ja auch schon eine ganze
weile läuft bei mir das ist eine mischung aus ursprünglich mal gewesen aus go plus
c allerdings ist der interop mit c und go alles andere als schön das ist auch sowas
wo sich so das ist auch ein thema wo mir diese dieses elite denkt dieses auf elite tun von
manchen gruppen äh voll auf den sack geht ja in der go community ist es zum beispiel
so die sagen man braucht keine ordentliche zusammenarbeit zwischen go und c plus plus
weil und jetzt kommt die logik schlechthin weil man kann ja alles in go neu programmieren
was ist das für eine absolut idiotische logik ja ich kann alles in jeder sprache neu programmieren
aber das ist nicht sind uns weg der sache und es gibt nun mal viel was in c ist was man
gerne verwenden möchte allen voran ffm pack ffm pack ist vielleicht noch mit g streamer
aber ffm pack ist was codex angeht einfach einfach besser umfangreicher ffm pack ist
das ding schlechthin was ich total oft brauche und das ist halt nun mal in c und was bringt
es mir da wenn mir in den in den go fanatiker sagt ja dann mache halt kein ffm pack sondern
nehmen lasst die leute mal ffm pack in go nach programmieren was ein spaß macht keiner
einfach mal nebenbei so meinung zu valorant immer noch nicht gespielt was ich bisher gesehen
habe gefällt es mir eigentlich ganz gut wie gesagt vor allem dass es mehr c s ist als
overwatch finde ich gut wieso nicht brainfuck nutzen exzellente frage wie kommst du das
was moment real worst player eu habe ich übrigens mein fragen mein fragentool gestartet
fällt mir gerade auf excellent habe ich da ganz die frage nehme ich hier durchgehen
sehr schön wobei so lange ich die fragen noch so sehe ist auch ok wir machen mal das
aquarium das bissel was tut wie kommst du wie kommt dass du sie schrecken heißt findest
aber gar kein fan von java bist ich habe so gute frage also ich meine mal mitbekommen
zu haben dass du java schrecklich findest ist auch so java kann ich überhaupt nicht ab
ich finde es ist einfach die schöne gesprache es hat gewisse ähnlichkeiten also man sieht
das eindeutig dass sie schaab vieles gemacht hat weil es in java gut funktioniert aber
diese schaab leute hatte zumindest in der entstehungszeit war jetzt auch noch die haben
die sachen einfach schöner gelöst ja zum beispiel dass du weiß gar nicht ob man mittlerweile
ordentliche generics in java hat ich glaube ich glaube mittlerweile schon und auch viele
andere konstrukte die die eingebaut haben beispielsweise link ist ganz cool was sie
eingebaut haben oder auch die lambda konstrukte und die machen relativ viel neue sachen sie
schaab ist beispielsweise mittlerweile ziemlich funktional geworden und ich finde sie schaab
ist einfach nur in der supersprache vor allem dort net core ist auch eine super runtime
gefällt mir persönlich ist das einfach lieber als als java aber auch wenn ich java immer
am flame bin ja wir haben ja wir haben ja nicht umsonst hier quasi ein extra eigenes java
java immerhots ja man kann bedenkenlos sachen in java machen warum nicht was hältst du
von pyson super huge ist ruby tot antwort ruby ist die seite kenne ich die seite gibt
schon ewig die seite die seite gibt es ewig aber ruby ist schon nicht mehr so angesagt
da mein wirklich tot ist eine programmiersprache ja nie wenn sie jemals ordentliche verbreitung
hatte ich mein guckt euch mal guckt euch cobalt an cobalt ist immer noch da so alle fragen
durch hab welches videoschnittprogramm benutzt du mit welchen also für mein youtube zeug
verwende ich immer sony vegas aber ich glaube noch in version 14 oder so 13 oder so habe
ich mir mal gekauft und seitdem benutze ich das und zum rendern einstellungen gar keine
die ich kann ja alles mit ffm pack ich renne da quasi unkomprimiert oder mehr oder weniger
unkomprimiert raus mit vegas frame für frame und füttert das in ffm pack on the fly da
gibt es so ein plugin was die sachen abgreift und nach ffm pack schiebt wie findest du
andere jvm sprachen wie kotlin damit habe ich wenig gemacht ich habe ein paar webcasts
gesehen und die sprache fand ich wirklich nice genauso wie auch eine sprache sprache
die mir ganz gut gefällt oder den framework plus sprache was mir ganz gut gefällt wo
ich mal gerne was drinnen machen würde wenn es denn dann auch mal auf dem desktop gut
funktioniert ist da also beziehungsweise flutter flutter ist ja der neueste scheiß aktuell
was uis angeht und ich hoffe die sind mit flutter auf dem desktop kommen die ordentlich
voran dass es vielleicht mal so in zwei drei jahren ready ist weil ich habe es nicht oft
genug gesagt ordentliche desktop ui frameworks gibt es halt nicht vor allem vor allem cross
platform jetzt habe ich was falsches gelöscht oder ich lösche erst mal die alten die
erst mal die alten fragen ich ich das ist fail ich habe hier nur kein datum ich habe
hier nur eine nur eine uhrzeit vorne gemacht also wählen hatten wir schon das hatten wir
auch schon
bin ich mir gar nicht sicher ob ich das gesehen habe das war vom letzten stream schon wehle
und habe ich auch was dazu gesagt das verwende ich nicht ich verwende das hier frame ich
glaube das ding das ist ziemlich simpel das schreibt einfach die unkomprimierten frames
in quasi in so eine warteschlange rein die man damit ffmpeg abgreifen kann das ist total
simpel da muss ich da klicke ich in den wegas klicke ich einfach auf rendern und dann mache
ich auf der kommande zeile ffmpeg an mit meinen optionen und gut ist
ok jetzt mal eigentlich ein thema ich wollte euch ja was zeigen also ich habe nämlich
ein bisschen was gebastelt ultra nice zumindest für meine anwendungszwecke daheim ich überlege
gerade ob ich euch irgendwie ein foto zeigen kann heute ich mache mal ein foto ich muss
mal kurz wo habe ich meinen habe ich mein handy da ich mache ich mache ich mal schnell
ein foto und komm wieder an rechner es dauert eine minute damit wieder da
so und zwar jetzt ist natürlich nur die preisfrage wie kriege ich das gescheit von meinem handy
wir brauchen mal wieder eine ordentliche das gab es hier im igua alternative was gibt
es denn da schönes ich muss irgendwo mal ein foto hochladen post images blog post images
kann man das anklicken ohne dass man auf pornseite landet ok post images.org da gehen wir jetzt
mal hin ich muss jetzt mal vom handy hochladen dann zeige ich euch mal was ich gebastelt
habe post images.org oh subscriber wo ane gar kein subscriber an den host der krieger hat
mich gehorst für 672 zuschauer ach du scheiße alter dankeschön für den host huge easy clap
damit habe ich jetzt überhaupt nicht gerechnet was habt ihr gespielt war war zone oder was
habt ihr gemacht heute ist hier richtig er heckermann stream angesagt und ich versuche
gerade so richtig so richtig boomer style weil ich dazu blöd für bin von meinem handy
den bild hochzuladen dass ich euch zeigen kann ich kriegt das irgendwie nicht gebacken
foto library ja danke danke danke für den host huge kott rennt erhalten zusammen naja
kott spieler spieler schon ewig immer richtig nicht mehr richtig call of duty das letzte
das letzte call of duty was ich gespielt habe war ein bisschen in der beta modern warfare
und danach aber dazwischen habe ich glaube ich ein paar ausgelassen ist echt nicht mehr
so meins gewesen dann upload so mal gucken ob der upload jetzt funktioniert ich frag mich
halt ob sie irgendwann noch mal die die ja ja schon klar wo ich hochladen kann ich brauche
irgendwas wo ich das vom handy aus machen kann aber ich hab ich hab schon was ich frag
mich ob sie sehen ob sie irgendwann mal wieder die kurve die kurve kriegen soll also ich
hab hochgeladen zeig mal hier post image punkt cc kommt cool dass jetzt auf einer porn
seite rauskommen oder so b gg 3w v 5m so das habe ich gebastelt das wollte ich euch zeigen
genau und zwar das ist meine gegensprech anlage von der tür unten und das ist das
wo wir heute ein bisschen was für programmieren müssen weil ich festgestellt habe dass es
ziemlich blöd ist microcontroller zu updaten übers wlan wenn man scheiße programmiert
und man nicht mehr dran kommt weil die dinge in der wand stecken also was ich gebastelt
habe ist was der fack aber ein bisschen so also vielleicht spiegel ich mich hier irgendwo
ich bin nicht ganz sicher spiel ich spiele ich hoffe ich spiele mir nicht zumindest
dass es hier die gegensprech anlage von von meiner tür und
der echte max fbs ja patrick mache ich nachher ein heutzutage sagt man ja nicht mehr muss
lachen sondern muss kecken also das habe ich noch nicht gehört dass man kecken muss aber
dass man dass man roffeln muss oder oder lullen habe ich schon gehört aber aber kecken habe
ich gehört nee hast du was ging im igur ja dass es nur auf dem handy mit der app gescheit
funktioniert und die app der meinung ist alle bilder aufmachen zu müssen in der app anstatt
dem browser gekacken so und zumindest was ich probiert habe ist ich hätte man foto machen
müssen wo das wo das wo das offen ist und zwar ist das die gegensprech anlage von von meiner
ja von meiner also dann das telefon zu meiner gegensprecher anlage an der tür jo hast du
eigentlich ein techniker gemacht was ist ein techniker machen nie habe ich nicht also
gelernt habe ich mal fach informatiker system integration vor über zehn jahren lullen
genau aber ein techniker habe ich gemacht wozu auch oder was meinst du nur ja also um
einfach zu eigentlich in sache zu kommen ich habe hier dahinter ich müsste das erst
noch mal aufmachen euch zeigen weil das sieht das sieht sehr abenteuerlich aus da drinne
ich habe da ich habe da leider kein bild von gemacht zu machen ich habe das telefon von
der gegensprecher anlage aufgemacht und habe einen microcontroller dahinter gestopft nämlich
so ein ganz kleiner sp 32 so ein da der ist so daumen daumen die hälfte vom daumen groß
also die ist wirklich ziemlich ziemlich klein das teil man zieht ja ja ja man schön vergleicht
guck mal das ist der daumen von dem hast du es ungefähr so wie die erste so wie der
erste abschnitt vom daumen das ist wirklich ziemlich ziemlich kleines ding so und so ein
controller habe ich hier dahinter gemacht und dann habe ich noch was gebastelt zeige
ich euch gleich der erkennt jetzt wann das war das klingelt so und wenn das klingelt
also der erkennt nicht nur wann das klingelt und zwar ich habe mir auch noch einen hall
sensor gekauft dass so ein ding dass ein sensor der magnetfelder erkennen kann das ding ja
das sieht das sieht exakt so aus so ein teil hier ist das habe ich da angeschlossen und
die habe den habe ich dann in den telefonhörer dort wo der telefonhörer reinkommt dahinter
geschoben das heißt der controller kriegt jetzt mit wenn das klingelt und wann hast
du die 300 IQ Sachen gemacht die habe ich offline gemacht die habe ich nicht im stream
gemacht so und die ich hätte echt mal photos von machen sollen und den den magnet sensor
habe ich hinter das telefon gestöpselt das heißt ich kriege jetzt mit wenn ihr jemand
den höre abnimmt und ich kriege mit wenn es klingelt und dann mache ich folgendermaßen
wenn das klingelt dann geht ja auf dem tablet die kamera aus die außen ansicht von der
kamera auf die ich überlege kann ob ich die euch zeigen kann ich habe sie euch ja schon
mal gezeigt aber dann ich muss gerade mal vorher gucken ob da nicht irgendwas geliegt
wird doch wird zu viel geliegt kann ich euch gerade nicht zeigen die außen ansicht von
der kamera zumindest geht dann das tablet an und man sieht darauf die außen ansicht
von der kamera so das habe ich gebastelt und dabei ist mir aufgefallen dass es ziemlich
blöde ist wenn man sowas hier hinter die wenn man sowas hier einbaut quasi unter dem
ding in der dose in der wand wenn man so einen controller da einbaut der ist nur per wlan
erreichbar und man möchte einen update machen ich meine da hätte ich auch vorher drauf
kommen können dass es keine so tolle idee ist controller zu updaten die in der wand
stecken aber nichtsdestotrotz funktioniert ich meine ich habe ja ich bin ja nicht kompletter
noob was das angeht ich habe eingebaut dass ich übers wlan updaten kann das funktioniert
das problem ist nur dass das ein bisschen ein bisschen verbackt ist zum beispiel kackt
es ab wenn jemand den hörer in der zwischenzeit abnimmt während das update läuft und so richtig
ab sodass ich resetten muss und resetten bedeutet in dem fall aufmachen aufmachen abstöpseln
und wieder einstöpseln und das ist auch ziemlich kacke wenn man das jedes mal ich zeige euch
mal wie so ein telefon von innen aussieht genau hier erkennt man es ganz gut so sieht
das telefon von innen aus also sprich da oben ist so viel platz drinne das klingt so
wie wenn es schon mal passiert wäre ja natürlich deswegen will ich ja auch ein bisschen was
dran machen also ihr seht hier oben ist relativ viel platz drin das ist das ding was an der
wand hängt und hier oben ist relativ platz viel viel platz drin also sprich was ich gemacht
habe ist was ich gemacht habe ist hier ist dann so die die die wie nennt man das unterputzdose
die dose in der wand wo halt das dann draufsitzt und da kommen paar kabel auch aus dem keller
und strom und sonst was drüber raus und ich habe im endeffekt hier oben nen zwölf volt
auf fünf volt spannungswandler reingepappt weil man das braucht für die controller und
noch ein paar andere sachen kleben also also mein gehäuse von der von dem telefon ist
relativ voll ja da passt nicht mehr viel rein und hier dahinter hier hinter dem bord steckt
der steckt der sensor für die erkennung von magnetfelder und hier hinten ist ja auch
die stelle wo man den telefonhörer dann quasi drauf macht auf der anderen seite so und was
ich halt verkackt habe ist bei dem bei dem update mechanismus ja und was macht das ding
jetzt eigentlich alles wie gesagt man das erkennt wenn die wenn wenn einer klingelt
dann geht die kamera an und das tablet geht an mit dem mit dem jeweiligen kamerabild von
vom vom von der eingangstür und vom hof und dadurch dass ich erkenne dass man den hörer
abnimmt und auflegt kann ich das tablet halt auch wieder ausschalten früher habe ich so
gemacht bei den ersten versuchen dass das tablet einfach zwei minuten angeblieben ist
und dann wieder ausgegangen ist aber mit der mit dem hörer ist das noch viel schöner
da kann ich nämlich den höre abnehmen und dann geht das auch so an ohne dass jemand
klingelt und vor allem wenn jemand geklingelt hat nicht mit fertig und legt den hörer wieder
auf gehts gleich wieder gehts gleich wieder aus hast du einen cute klingelton ne das hat
einen standard klingelton den kann man nicht ändern so jetzt muss ich mal kurz chat gucken
ob ich irgendwas übersehen habe das hatten wir schon das hatten wir auch schon was hast
du gegen imiko wie gesagt die app sagt ja ja ja emote oder das müssen wir gleich das
müssen wir gleich einbinden ganz wichtig klingelton samplerschein add to my channel so patrick
ist drinnen kann aber sein dass es ein bisschen dauert so techniker weiß ich nicht genau
was du damit gemeint hast hast du mal fancy zones ausprobiert ich glaube das haben wir
ausprobiert hatten wir das nicht ausprobiert in einem der letzten streams wir hatten doch
irgendwelche tiling window manager ausprobiert für windows ach nee das ist das power toys
ding ne das haben wir nicht ausprobiert wie gesagt sinn ist dass die außen kameras angehen
wenn es klingelt ich habe schon jede menge so controllers hier im haus verteilt und die
haben alle das gleiche problem das ist das wo ich heute mal was ausprobieren will ich
habe noch ein paar sp 82 66 aber ich versuche jetzt alles durch sp 32 zu ersetzen einfach
weil sp 32 programmieren deutlich angenehmer ist als sp 28 66 und also ein als der sinn
in dem fall hier hiervon ist jetzt dass wenn einer klingelt dass ich die kameras direkt
sehe das funktioniert auch ziemlich gut muss man sagen ich zeige euch noch mal was ich
da für eine für eine mini schaltung gebastelt habe dass das ganze so funktioniert und zwar
muss ich mal gucken ob ich das ob ich das jetzt fände was man ja hier gibt es das vielleicht
noch ein bisschen ein bisschen höher aufgelöst das telefon die telefon inne rein vielleicht
und ein bisschen höher aufgelöst dass man auch mal was erkennt nie wirklich oder zumindest
das hier sind die klemmen wo die kabel aus dem keller reinkommen wo es da auch noch steht
zwischen sp 32 zwischen sp 32 und sp 32 66 der hauptsächliche unterschied ist dass der
sp 32 schnellere cpus hat und 2 bzw. 3 cpus wogegen der sp 82 66 nur eine hat das heißt
wenn man sachen parallel machen will ist es mit sp 32 deutlich angenehmer das heißt nämlich
auch dass man eine cpu hat die komplett wlan und kommunikation machen kann und eine cpu
die halt den custom code ausführen kann das ist schon mal grundsätzlich viel der punkt
der es viel einfacher macht beim sp 82 66 das oftmals das problem wenn du irgendwie
zu lange blockst dass er sich neu startet und sowas genau der sp 28 hat auch bluetooth kommt
noch dabei der hat auch mehr ram er hat ne du kannst mehr du kannst vom flash mehr fürs
betriebssystem verwenden als was heißt für betrieb für den für deinen für dein dein
programm verwenden es macht insgesamt ist es deutlich angenehmer du hast mehr pins du
hast deutlich mehr pins du hast mehr analog digital konverter beim sp 32 die musik gerade
abgekackt kann es sein die musik war einfach nur vorbei hallo musik excellent jetzt geht's
ja das ist also das sind so die unterschiede mir einfallen der sp 32 ist auch eher an an
bastler und und hobbyleute und heimbereich gerichtet wohingegen der sp 28 66 so bisschen
für eher für gerätehersteller gedacht ist dementsprechend ist der sp 32 auch ein bisschen
angenehmer zu programmieren also ich versuchte meine ganzen alten kontrolle durch sp 32 zu
ersetzen zumindest also das ist das wollte ich ja gerade zeigen er fragt nämlich wie ist denn
der sp mit der gegensprecherlage verbunden hat die dafür verfügbare pins oder funktioniert
das nur über den halt sensor also woher bekommt der sp das signal her wenn es klingelt genau
das wollte ich das wollte ich nämlich eigentlich erzählen ich hatte ich muss mal kurz ein
bisschen auswählen ich hatte verschiedene ideen wie man das machen kann nur mal dass
man sieht dass es dass es viele varianten gibt bei sowas zum ziel zu kommen und zwar
wenn man feststellen will mit einem controller ob das telefon klingelt das erste was mir
eingefallen ist ist einen lautstärke sensor das ist das erste woran ich gedacht habe
es gibt nämlich quasi kleine mikrofone die nix anderes machen wie wenn ein klang über
ein gewisses level kommt ein signal auszugeben so nach dem motto lautstärke ist ein gewissen
level signal das kann man schön an an die pins anschließen oder kriegt man das mit
das ist eine variante das erste woran ich gedacht habe aber das ist ein bisschen ein
bisschen fehler anfällig und schöner wäre es wenn ich auch noch den zustand mit bekomme
halt sprich klingelt es gerade wird gerade telefoniert oder ist gar nix so und das mache
ich folgendermaßen dazu muss man wissen wie dieses gegensprecherlagen ding intern funktioniert
das ist das ist ein abenteuerliche akane wissenschaft da steht auch nirgendswo so richtig
aber ich habe ein bisschen im internet geforscht wie der kram funktioniert und zwar um klingeln
zu signalisieren jetzt haltet euch fest dass es das ist pains champ was die leute basitel
sich ausgedacht hat wirklich schwarze magie zumindest um kabel zu sparen weil man muss
ja immerhin ein kabel liegen von der tür bis zu den telefonen ja um kabel zu sparen haben
wir das so gemacht dass sie nur zwei kabel brauchen also einmal ground und einmal halt
signal so und wie sie das machen ist die schicken wenn es klingelt stellen die auf dem signalkabel
stellen sie 24 volt ein und wenn das telefon quasi feststellt 24 volt ist auf dem dem
signalkabel dann klingelt dann wenn einer den höre abnimmt geht das runter auf 15 volt
und daran erkennt man sprachverbindung ist an und dann schalten sich die anderen telefone
auch ab und es wird quasi auf dieses auf die gleiche leitung dann auch analog einen voice
signal drauf moduliert ganz merkwürdiges zeug was sie da treiben und um den ruhezustand
zu signalisieren also sprich keine sprechverbindung und keine klingel keine klingelt die klingelt
dann sind das 18 volt auf der leitung excellent ja excellent also das wirklich big brain was
die jungs da gemacht haben zumindest ist das gar nicht schlecht weil man braucht nur zwei
kabel so und wie ich jetzt den controller damit verbunden habe ist folgendermaßen das
muss ich mal den forums post raussuchen ich glaube beim iop broker war das oh die musik
ich muss mal kurz die anleitung raussuchen weil ich da gebastelt habe das hier ah jetzt
das ist das richtige genau und ich habe zufälligerweise diese anleitung hier gefunden und ich war
erstmal komplett abgeschreckt habe ich das wtf was treibt der typ da das ist übrigens
das innere vom telefon was ihr hier seht das ist das hier wo er da gerade dran rumlötet
habe ich mir gedacht nee ehrlich gesagt habe ich da jetzt nicht so wirklich bock an meinem
telefon rumzulöten weil naja vielleicht war ich kaputt und ich will kein neues kaufen
so da habe ich ein bisschen weiter gescrollt dann festgestellt der hat noch eine deutlich
bessere anleitung die viel einfacher ist die kommt hier genau und das ist das ding was
ich gebaut habe ich kann euch mal ich kann euch mal erklären oder ich kann versuchen
zu erklären was das macht hier oben geht es auf die pins
hier hat man die pins sprich dass hier oben sind die kabel die auf den controller gehen
also sprich das hier geht auf einen ground pin und das hier geht auf irgendeinen input
auf irgendeinen kann man sich aussuchen ist egal muss man dann bloß wenn man das programmiert
die firmen dann sich halt merken welcher pin das ganze ist also sprich dass hier oben ist
relativ uninteressant das ist der anschluss an den an den controller da erzähle ich erst
mal was das da unten ist der irgendwie das foto ein bisschen klein gemacht hat weil da
gibt es nämlich noch ein besseres foto da das ist gut das foto erkennt man also wie
gesagt das sind die kabel zum controller was geht max invasion ich rede mich über z++
auf und wir basteln ein bisschen rum das geht mal gucken wie lang es geht ich habe nur so
viele zuschauer gerade weil nämlich der krieger gehorstet hat vorher 150 jetzt habe ich zwischenseitig
mal 400 oder gut aber ich gebe ja zu die die themen übersteigen sich gerade nicht so nicht
so richtig auf der einen seite hier heckermann stream auf der anderen seite war es wahrscheinlich
vermutlich war so ein stream oder so timo t bis exzellent nahme exzellent abonnieren
zwitsch bleiben dankeschön für den zapp so ok kommen wir mal zum thema zurück wie ich
den ganzen kram verbunden habe das ziel ist es ja dass ich mit bekomme wenn die anlage
klingelt und wie ich gerade erklärt habe ist man erkennt daran ob die anlage klingelt
wenn auf der leitung 24 volt sind 24 volt signalisiert klingeln also wenn ich das jetzt
richtig verstanden habe schreibt desorschen ließ der sp einfach die spanung von der gegensprache
lager fast fast war mal ab ich fertig erklärt also fast es ist ähnlich ich hatte vorher
den raspberry dran mit einem analog digital konverter der exakt das gemacht hat der hat
einfach der hat einfach gemessen wie viel spanung auf der leitung ist und aber 24 volt
hatte das ausgegeben wobei ich sagen muss einen kompletten raspberry zero für so eine
einfache aufgabe war ein bisschen viel und dazu kam dass der raspberry zero hier neben
rausgehangen hat weil er nicht mehr da reingepasst hat war zu fett im endeffekt so sick so das
heißt man möchte dass die knallen hier haben an irgendeinem input pin wenn 24 volt anliegen
so und was der typ jetzt gebastelt ist eigentlich mega big brain wie gesagt verbindung zum
controller hier unten verbindung zum zum zum crown pin vom telefon das sieht man hier
das ist das hier das hier unten ist der crown pin vom telefon das ist auch uninteressant
das richtig interessante ist die kombination aus diesen drei teilen so also nur zu sagen
dass das ist relativ so und das ist das ist das interessante zwar dass hier unten oder
das da oben ist ein 470 oben widerstand das ist halt in den widerstand da gibt es 30
verschiedene varianten von da gibt es nichts da gibt es nicht viel zu sagen aber das ist
das interessante hier das ist das interessante ich wusste gar nicht ich bin ja nicht so
der nicht so der wahnsinn elektronik bastler ich werde zwar besser mit der zeit aber ich
bin ziemlich ja nur was elektronik bastel angeht ja ich habe da auch schon faser kaputt
gemacht und das ist genau das ist das ist eine 10er diode oder z diode eine 20 volt
z diode und der typ hat ein h hier drauf das sind 20 volt z diode das bedeutet das ding
ist quasi quasi so eine art wie nennen wir es mal so eine art schranke so eine art damm
ist das das ist so eine art damm also sprich das ist eine 20 volt z diode das heißt wenn
hier auf der seite weniger als 20 volt sind geht nichts durch sobald es aber mehr als
20 volt sind leitet die auf einmal durch so und das coole daran ist in kombination mit
diesem gerät hier oben also um soweit zu erklären im prinzip ist das nichts anderes wie eine
schranke die anfängt durchzuschalten wenn wenn mehr als 20 volt anliegen und es liegen
mehr als 20 volt an wenn wenn es klingelt so dann schalte das durch der widerstand ist
wahrscheinlich einfach nur dazu da dass es kein kurzschluss hier dazwischen gibt kann
ich mir vorstellen und das interessante ist das hier was ist das das ist ein sogenannter
optokoppler ich glaube da ist gar keine led drinne ist
ein optokoppler ist eine led drinne ne das keine led drinne ach die led meinst du meinst
intern ich hab gesagt du wolltest irgendwie den status anzeigen lassen intern ja klar
intern ist eine led drinne oder irgendwas was licht macht in irgendeiner art und weise
zumindest das ist ein optokoppler ich versuch das mal zu erklären was das ding macht wie
gesagt ich bin ich so der oberklasse elektroman aber das ist ein bisschen zu vergleichen
mit so einem es kann man ein bisschen mit einem relay vergleichen nur mit dem unterschied
dass die signale optisch sind also sprich hat er gerade oplokoppler gesagt optokoppler
für optik was das was das ding macht ist das hat einen schalter drinne das hat hier
einen schalter auf der seite das ist ein bisschen so ein bisschen wie den relay hier ist hier
ist ein schalter dazwischen und der schalter der geht an o subs leute das gem train ich
ich lese gleich alle subs vor ich war gerade so erzählen bist mal auf 9000 sechs monatlich
huge sub excellent und das gem train ist auch am start habe ich habe ich die anderen subs
habe ich die vergessen immer kurz gucken den hatten wir da sonst noch den nico rock falls
ich vorgelesen haben neun monate huge brain sub dankeschön exquisite subscriber das gem
train genau und im prinzip ist hier ein schalter dazwischen und der schalter schaltet
wenn hier also wenn hier strom durchfließt also sprich wenn der stromkreis hier geschlossen
ist dann schaltet der schalter ein auf der seite so dass man das signalisiert damit
eine led dass die signalübertragung geht mit einer led das heißt diese beiden stromkreise
hier oben und da unten sind komplett voneinander entkoppelt also sprich der schalter hier auf
der seite schaltet so ein bisschen wie bei einem relay bei dem relay ist es quasi mit
einem magnet und hier ist es halt über led und empfänger auf der anderen seite so das
heißt wenn hier strom durchfließt oder das hier geschlossen ist dann wird auch das geschlossen
und das schöne daran ist dass ich dann mit bekomme sobald das hier geschlossen ist auf
meinem microcontroller dass jemand geklingelt hat also sprich dieses konstrukt hier unten
sorgt dafür wenn über 20 volt anliegen auf der auf der leitung von der klingel was beim
klingeln der fall ist dann geht es hier durch dadurch dass es hier durch fließt wird das
hier geschaltet auch über die seite und was noch das ist ein foto ja ist es auch das ich
dachte es ist so was wie ein relay ich weiß ich wie es besser erklären soll so und das
das richtig gute daran ist und das richtig gute daran ist dass die zwei seiten entkoppelt
sind das heißt es brummt auch nix beim raspberry pi hatte ich das problem da war das quasi
ganz alles an der gleichen leitung angeschlossen auch das netzteil da hat es gebrummt und dadurch
dass die beiden seiten entkoppelt sind brummte auch nix erst mal mit einer autobatterie seine
klingel kurz schließen ja man weiß nicht was da alles passieren kann aber bis jetzt läuft
das ganze wunderbar zumindest mit diesem ding mit dieser mit diesem konstrukt an gp au pin
17 habe ich glaube ich 14 was intern pin pin 17 ist wer ist eigentlich bei den chinesen
auf die glorreiche idee gekommen die gp au pins und die gp au und und die pins intern
anders zu benennen das frage ich mich seit anfang an ja das hatten die beim esp 82 66
auch schon das war dann gp au 14 und und pin nummer 17 das das könnte fast vom c++ cremium
sein so bescheuert wie das ist unglaublich beknackt so und ja so funktioniert das ganze
also dass die seite wird ans telefon angestöpselt beziehungsweise da wo wo das wo das telefon
aus der wand kommt die anschlüsse für das für die gegensprech anlage aus der wand
kommt also sprich da das auf eins das auf sieben und das hier auf ground vom microcontroller
und das hier auf den gp au pin das das rote verdienter primes ab dankeschön huge high
q subs so und so funktioniert das ganze das gem train stufe 1 abgeschlossen jetzt kommt
das gem train stufe 2 leute die bahn rollt mal wieder döner bezahlt das schlimme ist
mein döner mann hat zu dank korona der ist nicht mehr da der wollte angeblich letzte
woche aufmachen ist nicht aufgetaucht der laden ist einfach nicht nicht da ist einfach
da steht da steht immer noch dran machen wieder auf glaube ich am achten oder ne wat kalender
am am am sechsten steht da drauf machen wieder auf am sechsten und der ist einfach nicht
aufgetaucht steht immer noch dran der laden ist zu sogar lieferando hat den mittlerweile
schon rausgenommen oder halt auf dauer geschlossen gesetzt weil die wahrscheinlich halt wieder
aufgemacht haben weil das eingetragen hat und dann hat er keine bestellung bearbeitet
haben sie wieder zugemacht ich hoffe ich hoffe ich hoffe nicht er ist weg koronat mein döner
mann beim gem train bin ich doch am start so laurenz dankeschön zwei monate so viel dazu
ich glaube ich habe das jetzt ausführlich genug erklärt das ganze wie das ganze um
so länger ich jetzt hier um mein elektronisch zeug laberna um so weniger bock habe ich wirklich
jetzt c++ zeug zu programmieren ich muss schon kotzen wenn ich dran denke eigentlich
eigentlich habe ich gar keinen bock drauf wieso macht man sich eigentlich die mühe
und hört nicht einfach ob es klingeln und nimmt dann ab jetzt macht man doch guck mal
das ist ja das aktuelle konstrukt da höre da tablet wenn du hörst ob es klingelt und
dran gehst hast du immer noch kein kamerabild das doch gerade der sinn davon es klingelt
und es geht die kamera auf vom tor beziehungsweise vom hof das kannst du noch so viel hören und
dran gehen davon kriegst du immer noch kein kamerabild und das ist ja grad der sinn und
des weg dahinter ich will mitbekommen wenn es klingelt dass ich dann das tablet einschalten
kann und das bild von der kamera im hof und an der tür aufmachen kann so darf man jetzt
zum geburtstag ein buch schenken das elektrotechnik für dummes heißt das dürftest du machen
aber du weißt gar nicht wann ich geburtstag habe außerdem gibt es genug tutorials ich
mache sehr immer bei allen sachen wo ich keinen plan davon habe ich habe so eine so
eine eine universale taktik ich lerne sachen immer dann wenn ich sie brauche das ist eigentlich
eine taktik die ist gar nicht mit der fahre ich eigentlich ganz gut also sprich sobald
ich feststelle ich habe keine ahnung von irgendwas aber ich brauche das dann dann
und dann ist es auch ein thema was mich interessiert zumindest dann hat man auch bock drauf die
überlegen sachen zu lernen und dann bringt man dann bringt man auch relativ schnell durch
das ist cool das habe ich am letzten sogar schon auf auf auf twitter gezeigt es gibt
jetzt es gibt jetzt women 3d so lauren se ich glaube ich habe die schon vor gelesen
aber trotzdem dankeschön für die zwei monate der scam train leute level 2 scam train am
start wer hat noch nicht wer will noch zu spät zu spät vorbei leute es hat nicht mehr
gereicht wieso nicht einfach eine das ist das ist eine gute frage wieso nicht wo ist
es denn jetzt wieso nicht wieso nicht wieso nicht einfach eine komplette ip ip klingel
lösung für gebeute automatisierung hat mehrere gründe erstens weil ich der meinung bin dass
die eigentliche technik dahinter hier hinter dieser all school klingel über über über
draht absolut fehlerresistent ist und immer funktioniert ganz im gegensatz zu ip klingeln
die ja auch mal ein bisschen rumspacken können zum beispiel wenn es weder an gerade nicht
da ist oder irgendwas anderes und weil es geht
für monka weh hinzu wir haben schon ganz viele monkas monka weh monka weh mag ich nicht ich
mag monka giga monka giga ist eigentlich mein lieblings mein lieblings emote habe ich eigentlich
monka haben wir monka giga haben wir eigentlich monka giga oder habe ich das noch gar nicht
hinzugefügt haben wir monka giga überhaupt drin wir haben kein monka giga drin ok ich
habe es geedet monka giga ist mein absolutes lieblings emote beste monka giga monka s
ist beides gut monka shake mag ich auch noch monka weh mag ich nicht ich bin ja nicht
mainstream bin ich so mainstream genug für monka weh das war jetzt weder sowas von gestörter
twitch talk den hätte wahrscheinlich außerhalb auf dieser erde außer der twitch chat nur
wirklich keiner gecheckt also ich habe es hinzugefügt ich habe es hinzugefügt
oh wir haben noch ich komme gerade irgendwie nicht hinterher
den motion detection bei der kamera hat es auch getan
ne nicht wirklich da ist es ja laufend an ich hätte gerne desktop notify hör die klingel
das kannst du damit total einfach machen ich meine was meint ihr wie das funktioniert
dass das tablet angeht der der controller schalten schaltet ja nicht schaltet ja nicht
direkt das tablet an das geht folgendermaßen der controller erkennt dass es geklingelt
hat wir das erkennt habe ich ja gerade erklärt dann schickt eine mqtt message dass es geklingelt
hat mein home assistant heim automatisierung registriert die mqtt message und schickt
einen htp aufruf an die tablets oben und unten und da gehen die tablets an und dann ist noch
ein tasker job auf den tablets drauf der dafür sorgt dass in den browser aufgemacht wird
und die richtige uhr geladen wird mit den mit den kameras drauf
neonominus drei monate abonniert huge sub dankeschön
du bist auch auf 1337 IQ gekommen das ist gut ja da geht noch mehr mit jedem monat kommt
mehr dazu 1337 ich habe jetzt erinnert mich nämlich da gerade daran das ist das wlan
was ich verwende für mein streaming wlan ich habe ein extra wlan gemacht dass ich
meine wlan passworts dann mal liegen kann
guck mal wir haben raspberry raspberry pi emote also ist kein wirklich hype cherry wir
haben kein wirkliches raspberry pi emote aber sieht so ähnlich aus
choose my name sagt ich habe ja gestern oder heute ein projekt auf github gesehen mit dem
man eine regex pattern in ein fad 32 image umwandeln kann das als drive mounten kann
und dann damit text was
die beschreibung ist so wir dass ich mir überhaupt nichts darunter vorstellen kann
ich glaube aber nicht dass es an dir liegt sondern dass das projekt wahrscheinlich sehr
wirkt klingt
so ja ja will heute naja komisch
das ist am start mqtt esp home ftw esp home habe ich auch mal ein bisschen mit rumgespielt
ich mache lieber eigene sketches
was braucht man um den esp 32 an einen pc anzuschließen dazu muss man erst mal sagen
dass ein esp 32 nur der chip also nur die cpu und das stimmt auch nicht nur das fertige
der fertige chip vom hersteller ist das alles was man hier sieht ist kein esp 32 das ist
ein fertiges entwickler board mit einem esp 32 drauf der esp 32 ist eigentlich nur das
kleine ding da und wenn du aber so ein entwickler board hast oder sagen wir ein halbwegs ordentliches
esp 32 bord da kannst du das einfach per usb anschließen und funktioniert der der treiber
ist auch bei linux mal bin aus mit dabei den man braucht für zumindest bei linux ist auf
jeden fall mit dabei für die usb verbindung und dann brauchst du halt noch eine idee um
das ganze zu programmieren ich nehme ja plattform auf als wir irgendwann heute noch anfangen
zu mach schon mal auf falls wir irgendwann heute noch mal anfangen zu programmieren
dann siehst du es auch du brauchst nur usb dass dir dein ipad nicht geklaut wird ist ein
wunder warum das verstehe ich nicht oder ich habe den chat verlauf nicht nicht verfolgt
relax ja kann kann vorkommen aber du weißt mehr stream time bei mir im stream umso höherer
eq kannst du mir z plus plus beibringen nähe da bin ich der falsche
apropos password manager ja nein ja ja ja password manager beste ich verwende schon
seit jahren key pass nehme so im trend jetzt aktuell aber ich finde es immer noch der beste
der beste wenn man alles offline haben will und auch kein remote zugriff drauf braucht
welche ledigungs ist pro distro ist für anfänger ok bin dumm realtorque mint nehmen mint
oje sebaro das aber eklig wir machen informatik 2 jetzt husky und assembler da viel spaß
sebaro kann man den auch mit rast programmieren gerade noch nicht so richtig die sind dabei
die sind dabei aber so richtig gut funktioniert aktuell entweder reines c wenn man das offizielle
entwickler kit vom hersteller nimmt oder wenn man arduino verwenden will dann halt diesen
komischen c plus plus hybrid c c plus plus hybrid von arduino ja microsoft hat tatsächlich
mittlerweile ordentliches termin habe ich auch gesehen meinung zu one password habe ich nie
ausprobiert ich bin ich finde aber ich muss mal gucken ob es ist das mit dem roten logo
sind das die mit dem roten logo nee ganz was ganz hatten die nicht früher ein rotes logo
oder verwende ich das welcher password manager ist das der mit dem roten logo last pass genau
ja ja also ich halte von beiden nix ganz einfach aus dem grund wer seine passwörter und man
darf ja nicht vergessen was das ist im prinzip ist sind die passwörter und die die dazugehörigen
accounts ist ja das was so das so das online leben im endeffekt ausmacht ja das zugang
für alles und mit damit ich meine ich jetzt nicht nur die bank oder sowas sondern alles
was irgendwie privates drin ist was wichtiges drin ist foren zugänge mmo zugänge steven
bank twitter social media gedöns mails alles mögliche ja es ist einfach alles drinne und
gerade diese sachen möchte man doch nicht online bei einem anbieter hosten wo man nicht
weiß was er damit macht ja die meisten anbieter sagen ja wir würden niemals die passwörter
lesen und wir können die passwörter ja auch gar nicht lesen weil ihr kleinzeitig verschlüsselt
sind ganz ehrlich ich glaube die wenigsten haben die haben die software von den anbietern
ich will jetzt keinem unterstellen dass er das macht aber man weiß schlicht und ergreifend
nicht es hat keiner bisher die software wirklich mal auseinander genommen guckt geguckt was
die genau macht kleinseitige verschlüsselung schön und gut kann ja sein wer sagt mir dass
das nicht trotzdem irgendwie zum hersteller überträgt und außerdem will ich meine sachen
nicht online in irgendeiner cloud haben wenn es um die privatesten und wichtigsten sachen
geht die es gibt und das sind nun mal die passwörter für alle accounts und da können
da können die im prinzip noch so viel erzählen von wegen wo war das letzten ich hab es auch
letztens wieder gehört dass irgendeiner gesagt hat ja gebt uns gibt uns alle eure passwörter
gibt uns alle was war das denn alle eure logins und wir machen wir passen auch ganz und dann
kam raus und dann kam raus es war genau das gegenteil das war jetzt auch gar nicht so
lange her was war denn das zumindest auch gutes beispiel sind die ganzen bitcoin börsen
und so was es da gab so auch nach dem auto leute laden mal eure sachen bei uns hoch und
hoops wir machen dich und bei neuer zeug also man kann da im prinzip niemand trauen bitte
na bitt mit connect da eine bitt connect meine ich irgendwas was die letzten zeiten da in
letzten tagen aktuell war boah max bist du krank du hörst dich heute etwas anders an
ich höre mich eigentlich die letzten zwei stream schon genauso an weil ich habe habe
ich was falsch eingestellt oder so ich habe immer noch das gleiche ich habe hier mein kompressor an
und mein bisschen bisschen gehen es dürfte es dürfte der kompressor sein den habe ich
letztes mal aber die letzten zwei mal auch schon angehabt guck mal vielleicht habe ich
aber ich mikrofon zu laut auf 85 85 ist ganz schön laut oder 85 ist
78 runter aber wahrscheinlich kein großer unterschied oder ich glaube ich hatte immer 78
es macht es sollte jetzt dann kompressor übrigens kaum den unterschied machen ob
ich so habe oder so habe es sollte ungefähr es sollte ungefähr ungefähr gleich laut sein
das ist auch gerade das was der kompressor macht 69 also glaube ich glaube ich okay so
wie es so wie es ist gerade stellen wir mal mein geburtsjahr ein
so wir lassen es jetzt einfach so
ich komme leider nicht mehr drauf was das war da wollte ich nämlich auch letztens noch
was dazu sagen so nach dem oder ihr könnt viel erzählen wenn der tag lang ist aber keiner
hat sich jemals eure software angeguckt man hat das oft dass das alle anbieter sagen so nach dem
motto ja wir könnten ja aber die benutzer daten das ist das höchste gut was wir haben und wir
würden niemals und es kam schon so oft mittlerweile raus dass die anbieter doch sachen ausnutzen oder
anti cheat software die steam chats mitliest oder sonst was man kann dort prinzipiell niemand was
glauben und gerade aus dem grund für die privatesten sachen die man hat nämlich seine zugangspasswörter
niemals in die cloud legen von irgendjemand anderem aus prinzip nicht ohne ohne zu wissen
ob diese anbieter selbst jetzt irgendwie scheiße baut würde ich nie machen und irgendjemand hat
gerade geschrieben key pass beste und das ist so ich bin immer noch der meinung key pass ist das
beste super show 7 für 1 moin ja patrick ist aktuell ist ja ist ja bitt worden voll angesagt
ja die geschichte hier ist ja zur zeit recht im trend für password manager das ist ja eine
nachbau quasi davon zum selbst hosten also ich ich verwende key pass ich verwende für alles
key pass sondern seit jahren völlig key pass ja ja ich weiß gibt ich hab hier im steaming account
nix drinne
die musik sind alles hier wieder richtig er kam ein musik mit connect hast du einen bit max
affiliate link ich weiß gar nicht was das ist klingt nach einer klingt nach einer scam bitcoin
börse ist das mario kart ja mario kart wie sicherst du dein key pass fall ich stünde
das zwischen ein paar rechnern hast du schon mal bett rock linux angeschaut nee aber das
habe ich auf meiner liste das wollte ich mir mal angucken das war das nicht die bsd geschichte
war das nicht das was von die die distro die von bsd auf linux umgestiegen ist oder bring
es gerade durcheinander
moin jannik 0000 es gibt so viele anbieter die erzählt haben sie machen mit den daten
nix und haben trotzdem verkackt eines der beispiele in letzter zeit ich mitgekriegt
haben ist der hersteller von dem ich die kameras verwende die bett rock ist das wo du genau
verschiedene repos verwenden kannst genau stimmt das war das von denen von denen habe
ich ja die kameras allerdings mit custom firmen natürlich von denen habe ich ja die kameras
bei amazon com gekauft weil da sind die richtig günstig man kann sich auch in den china klon
für 932 kaufen huge bei amazon com kosten die 25 dollar oder so eine kamera so und von
denen hatte ich habe ich die kleine variante und ein bisschen größere variante die habe
ich hier im haus habe ich im hof und an der tür und überall habe ich hier kameras von
denen weil sie günstig sind und es eine halbwegs gute custom firmen gibt natürlich custom firmen
so und die sache ist die das ist nämlich einer der letzten größeren sachen wo ich
mitgekriegt habe was datensicherheit angeht und so was die haben auch immer erzählt so
nach dem motto ja wir brauchen eure zugangs daten hier und und wir müssen das alles über
unsere cloud machen mit euren video streams sonst wird das gar nicht richtig funktionieren
aber wir würden niemals würden wir da reingucken und wir können auch gar nicht reingucken
so und vor einem halben jahr noch nicht mal ganz vor vier monaten haben sie ein bisschen
was geleakt so und sie haben nicht nur sachen geleakt wie passt mal auf was da alles drin
stand fett stand da drinne fett ne body weight an der stand alles drinne von den leuten da
stand drinne wie groß wie schwer wie fett wie wie wie sonst was weil die stellen auch
wagen her body body scale und kameras natürlich super super kombination ja
höhe bone density protein intake alles geleakt deine waage von denen hatte ja und zumindest
gerade was beim thema kameras angeht gerade was bei themas kameras angeht die haben ja
auch gesagt ja die streams die müssen über die cloud gehen niemals könnte man die irgendwie
mitlesen und was kam raus die dinger waren absolut nicht richtig gesichert es gab offene
komplett offene china server wo die video streams drüber gegangen sind und es war eine
zeit lang möglich dass man wenn man eben von diesem leck was mitgekriegt hat bevor es
groß publik war sich quasi video streams von zwei millionen leute angucken konnte das
war voll für eine asche und die haben auch immer gesagt nein auf keinen fall und wir
könnten es gar nicht selber lesen und bla bla bla bla das ist so der letzte der mir
eingefallen ist der mich theoretisch betroffen hätte hätte ich die offizielle firma verwendet
aber ich verwende ja nicht die offizielle firma ich verwende ja custom firma und zwar
die custom firma hier das ist die custom firma die ich auf meinen kameras drauf hab
wenn ihr wollt kann ich euch die oberfläche mal zeigen von der kamera also die ist mit
custom firma viel viel besser als mit nicht custom firma ja zeig uns die oberfläche mach
ich da muss ich nur gerade mal kurz raussuchen welche kamera ich zeigen kann gerade mal raussuchen
welche ich zeigen kann ich zeig euch ich zeig euch die what the fuck htps ich zeig euch
die im keller weil da sieht man nicht viel drauf was was spack in der kram schon wieder
so rum jetzt wie genau ich zeig ich zeig euch die im keller da sieht man nämlich nicht
viel ja max videnz ist dahin bauen das müsste das ja fragen über fragen ja ihr seht jetzt
mein keller ip liegt umfg quai abonniert für vier monate dankeschön man sieht dass
man nicht sieht man sieht meine heizung im keller man sieht meine heizung im keller und
zwar was man darauf sieht ist dass der druck irgendwie ein bisschen bisschen wenig wieder
ist obwohl ich ihn schon hochgestellt habe huge product placement genau ich brauche
kohle von den zumindest die normalen kameras die haben keinerlei also die normalen weiss
cams die haben keinerlei web interface oder sonst was die kann man nur über die app bedienen
voll für den arsch so und jetzt passt mal auf was man alles cooles über die über die
über das web interface machen kann erst mal ganz wichtig dark theme einstellen als aller
wichtigste was man schon machen muss das ist das hat eine nachtsicht funktion ja das ist
genau ist ist ist ist infrared also man kann schon mal die kompletten ich nehme jetzt halt
die kamera weil man hat nichts großartig darauf erkennen kann außer meine heizung meine heizung
für die ich auch ein grafana dashboard habe das kennt das kennt ihr ja schon das kennt
er ja schon mein heizungs dashboard die die schon länger im stream sind die kennen das
heizungs dashboard so und ich tausche die zertifikate nicht die zertifikate lasse ich
überletzt encrypt für alle wichtigen domains automatisch tauschen für die kameras nicht
so also man kann sich erstmal alle möglichen übersichten angucken von der kamera man hat
die möglichkeit nachtsicht an- und auszumachen also ich kann zum beispiel die nachtsicht ausschalten
und irgendwann irgendwann aktualisiert das bild dann auch oder drei stunden später
ich refresh mal ah cock bild hat aktualisiert also nachtsicht ist aus das kann das sein
dass das rumspackt und ich automatisch aktualisiert irgendwie normalerweise sollte sollte das
automatisch aktualisiert alle paar sekunden na was auch immer nachtsicht ist aus mal nachtsicht
an ach jetzt aktualisiert auch automatisch ok was auch immer dann kann man noch einschalten
dass das tageslicht raus raus gekattet wird unser sonstige dinge also man kann man kann
leds an und ausschalten man kann motion detection anmachen es hat einen rtsp server zum stream
es hat einen mqtt klein dass ich sachen an meine heimautomatisierung schicken kann es
hat die unterschiedlichsten notification optionen bei bei bei bewegungsmensch bei bewegungs
bei der bewegungsmeldung jo man kann hin und her schwenken links rechts oben unten wenn
man eine kamera hat die das kann man kann stream qualität alles einstellen also sprich alles
sachen automatische tag nachterkennung alles sachen fragt mich nicht warum ich das ding
3d printer genannt habe das war mal das die kamera stand glaube ich mal neben meinem 3d
trocker jetzt steht sie im keller man sieht eindeutig 3d printer so und das geht alles
nur dank der custom firmware so siehts aus not secure meinst das hier so und das ist
die custom firmware die ich dafür verwende die hat auch so seine macken wofür braucht
man das ja dass man die streams von der kamera zum beispiel lokalen sie angucken kann ohne
die app vom hersteller ist das gerade das pokemon battles kann tatsächlich sein das
ist professor leiten ist das war nie meins die spieler serie kennst du ein gutes dashboard
für die küche wo man mit khaldaf und kataf arbeiten kann und tachseinfügen teilen fällt
mir jetzt nichts ein was ist eigentlich deine meinung zu dem video zu wählen und da wollte
ich ein eigenes video zu aufmachen zu dem machen zu dem während anti cheat unterm schritt
kann ich sagen die meisten leute wird das nicht jucken und was man auch sagen kann
man kommt nicht dran vorbei wenn man es spielen will das heißt die beste variante wenn man
es spielen will ist ein spielrechner ohne private sachen drauf right rootkit im endeffekt
schon wieso dann denkt der gameplay nehme ich dafür
wie liest du die daten von der heizung aus gibt es dafür eine schrittstelle ja gibt
das ist schwachsinn das kostet ist billiger das muss ja nicht oft ist ein usb kabel mit
zwei infrarot leds oben brauchst du ein kabel du steckst vorne an die heizung dran und
dann musst du dir auf github das hier runterladen und auf dem raspberry pi zum beispiel starten
und den usb ein raspberry pi dran machen dann kannst du auslesen da war ja mein heizungsmann
voll verwirrt dass ich ihm das so genau zeigen konnte wann meine heizung was macht
du warst der mit den 41 freqs ohne aufnahme ja das ist wirklich pippenhans ja das stimmt
draf vorrecht das ist nicht ganz von der hand zu weisen allerdings kann natürlich der user
space anti cheat nicht alles was der andere kann also auslesen oder vielleicht sachen
nachladen und sachen installieren und vielleicht auch im netzwerk irgendwelche sachen auskund
schafft also man weiß es ja nicht da kann auf jeden fall mehr machen ansonsten ich glaube
die auf die aufregung an sich bringt gar nichts weil riot wird das garantiert nicht ändern
nur weil es ein paar leute darüber aufbringen und die meisten leute interessiert es auch
gar nicht ich finde es ein bisschen bedenklich man muss aber sagen es sind nicht die ersten
die sowas machen das ist jetzt nicht so neu dass bei anti cheat halt teilweise mit oder
auch bei antivirus software mit virenähnlichen metoden gearbeitet wird ich bin skeptisch
die sehr anti cheat was bringt also klar eine gewisse gewissen basic schutz dass nicht der
größte kack noob da irgendwelche scripts an machen kann ist schon ist schon sinnvoll
ansonsten sind die hacker bzw die die cheats programmieren eigentlich immer zehn schritte
weiter als die die cheats verhindern wollen das war schon immer so vielleicht ein bisschen
kleiner geworden mittlerweile aber wird wahrscheinlich auch so bleiben das heißt ich glaube die
einzig wirklich wirksame anti cheat maßnahme die es geben könnte in zukunft ist ai basiertes
statistik auswerten das ist so ein punkt wo ich mir vorstellen könnte wenn das gut
gemacht ist und wenn wenn es da wenn es da mal ein richtig gutes produkt gibt dann würde
das den cheatern wirklich das leben schwer machen tp los da hast du recht die heizung
reparieren kann ich
es ist eigentlich technisch unmöglich in einer vm mit hart verpasst nur zu geben oder
fehlt einfach nur die lösung das ist weder technisch noch unmöglich noch fehlt die lösung
das geht jetzt schon ohne probleme mit den fischen das ist ascii aquarium das ist ein
skript das kannst du installieren oder runterladen was macht eigentlich was macht eigentlich
google stadia gerade so krieg sie ok aber warum dann nicht einfach die neue vm verwenden
hä welche neue vm können wir bisschen stadia stadia hate bekommen blockbotscher hört sich
besser an als vorher oder warum fragst du oder schlechter oder einfach nur anders komplett
tot ok reddit leute kann das sein dass ich jetzt schon eine halbe stunde am start bin
und eigentlich c++ zeug ein bisschen programmieren wenn du nix gemacht habe weil ich mich davor
irgendwie die ganze zeit drücke hast du ein only fans account natürlich
die vms meinte ich was anderes tibilius du hast recht das wäre sehr sinnvoll ja ich
habe übrigens die config files weil mich letzten noch jemand danach gefragt hat die
config files auf github mittlerweile hochgeladen vom einrichten von unserem linux warum habe
ich da bitteschön gekämpft und als eben als repo beschreibung also man sieht meine
commit messages sind natürlich schon mal absolut big brain ja ja ich habe zumindest
die config files vom linux einrichten stream gepusht falls das immer interessiert tritt
die maus für geht kommen ja wenn da irgendwas muss ja sein so also was ist mit stadia stadia
ist zum lachen schauen wir mal mal gucken mit dem addon habe ich da global twitch tv
emotes aber das kann ich nicht empfehlen global eigentlich zu haben weil das das layout von
seiten kaputt macht wenn da halt emotes drinnen vorkommen ich habe das ich habe das eigentlich
nur an für mein chat chat logger das nur für mein chat logger eigentlich laufen also
der chat logger der fragen an mich lockt und ich habe zu mal reingucken dass ich nichts
über sehe also wie viele neue posts gibt es denn new naja so tot ist stadia nicht also
guck mal zumindest ist auf reddit alle 15 minuten in post so tot kann das schon mal nicht sein
ich meine die spieler katalog ist glaube ich immer noch ziemlich ziemlich dead also serious
sam welches welcher teil ist das also man kriegt serious sam und ein bisschen bisschen komische
games die keiner will na gut der rest ist halt ist kein mensch brauche extremely generous
das ist das ist manchmal bei manchen leuten bin ich bin ich so ganz sicher ob das jetzt
wirklich jebaited ist oder ob die das wirklich so meinen ich würde ja erstmal davon ausgehen
dass ist jebait aber manche leute meinen so was ernst
CEO zweite kunde also ich meine so tot so tot ist was so ein made google stade routet in
die works ok und ein ganz video nicht abspielen ribb wahrscheinlich weil ich zu viel blocke
von der seite ich block ja nur 21 prozent von reddit
ja so tot so tot ist es nicht ich meine es ist doch es ist doch was los auf reddit also
wenn es alle 15 minuten einen neuen reddit post gibt ist sowas nicht tot klar es gibt
andere reddits da ist deutlich mehr los wenn man zum beispiel die kanada guck mal auf pass
of exile reddit da wird gespammt was das zeug hält aber die sind auch nicht mehr ganz dicht
da wird gespammt alle paar minuten was das zeug hält wobei man halt sagen muss dass die
sichtbar stadia natürlich schon erhofft haben dass bei ihnen mehr los ist als bei dem pass
of exile reddit was hältst du eigentlich von brave browser verwende ich nicht mehr 979 ist
halt nichts 140 games 100 450 games nada da bin ich mal gespannt da bin ich mal gespannt
ob davon was gescheites dabei sind das sind da bestimmt so geile games wie das final fantasy
wie das final fantasy mini mini rennspiel habt ihr das mitgekriegt das final fantasy
mini mini rennspiel was halt mega verbackter crap war mein sweeper mein sweeper deluxe
mein sweeper pro mein sweeper extended denn die leute sollen lieber die leute sollen
lieber super tux kratz spielen ja super tux fack wir haben es gar nicht mehr installiert
oh nee wir haben leute wir haben kein super super tux kratz mehr installiert wichtigste
wichtigste game was auf stadia kommen muss er wir brauchen unbedingt auf stadia haltet
euch echt super tux kratz brauchen wir oh das ist das falsche moment ich will super
ich will tux tux kratz will ich haben kratz nicht t max tux kratz tux racing brauche
ich ja super super tux kratz das brauchen wir und ich habe kein speicherplatz mehr leute
schnell aufräumen kratz noch mal speicher frei gemacht high end high skill command line
hexorn hier what try again yes ich will super tux kratz unbedingt ich brauche super tux
kratz oh super tux kratz let's go danach müssen wir 2 2 zeilen c++ programmieren
wo wir planen dass so die emotes ein damit damit mit meinem selbst gebastelten meme overlay
emote tool der sogar wie du gesagt gif und sounds kann ok tux kratz installiert ah yes
yes ah yes excellent
jawoll endlich mit was geht man gar ich muss sagen die neuen maps sehen gar nicht so schlecht
aus wie die alten super tux kratz das muss auch auf stadia kommen unbedingt super super
tux kratz beschleunigen auf maus eins ernsthaft auf der maus beschleunigen auf der maus auf
magenta gaming gar kein mario kart klone oder so ok genug also exit weg gut so wir müssen
mal was machen also es wäre ernsthaft leck das stream geht alles super tux kratz wird
immer noch weiter keine ahnung super tux kratz github mal gucken anscheinend vor zwei tagen
das letzte kommet
neues release eins punkt eins super tux kratz im jahr das ist mal was was ist das da oben
in der ecke leute dieses dieses ding da oben in der ecke verwirrt mich was ist das das
ist in ein auge und dann was ist das das ist das knu ich glaube das soll das knu sein
kann das könnte das das knu sein oder das mammut das knu das ist das knu das ist das
knu jetzt erkenne ich das boah das hat mich jetzt aber echt irritiert das ist so ein das
ich dachte das das sieht aus wie ein gesicht mit einem auge und auf der anderen seite irgendwas
eingefallen ist aber ich echt verwirrt jetzt aber das ist ok weil man weiß dass es eine
cool ist im endeffekt von der seite dann ist ok gleich mal tun ja super tux kratz ok leute
wo fangen wir an also wie gesagt ich habe hier einen
ich habe hier diesen diesen controller mini mini sp 32 wie gesagt so ein bisschen größer
wie der daumennagel also ganz kleines kackding und ich habe euch ja schon die ganze zeit
jetzt vorher habe ich euch zugeschwätzt was ich damit mache und sonst was und eine sache
die ich bei allen meinen microcontroller ein bisschen verkackt habe ist update über wlan
update über wlan funktioniert allerdings ziemlich verbackt und ich wollte jetzt mal gucken ob
es irgendwie möglich ist zwei zwei sachen ein ordentliches update über wlan hinzukriegen
was nicht abkackt und als wenn man was anderes macht und vor allem auch recover bar ist wieder
ohne dass ich in strom rein rausziehen muss da würde ich gern noch den restart kommando
einbauen und das ganze irgendwie in so eine kleine custom library verpacken dass ich den
all meine projekte einbinden kann und was ich als allererstes mal ausprobieren will
ist ob man irgendwie mit dem sp 32 eine websocket verbindung hinkriegt mit der ich debug ausgaben
per websocket rausschreiben kann das wird mich immer interessieren das heißt wir fangen
jetzt mal ganz simpel an was ich was ich gemacht habe ist ich habe schon mal meine wlan mein
wlan password hinterlegt in einer secrets datei dass ich nicht wieder mein wlan password
leake aber au au ask das ascii aquarium ist mittlerweile auf github tatsächlich da muss
ich aber angucken star star also das war alles da ich bin nicht eingeloggt aber ich muss
das ascii aquarium stan unbedingt da sieht man mal alte software muss ich unbedingt schlecht
sein das ascii aquarium ist immer noch super auch nach acht jahren so wir machen jetzt
mal was ganz billiges wir fangen mal ganz easy an wir connecten uns wir connecten uns
das ascii aquarium ist leider schlecht was gleich kommt der band das ascii aquarium
ist bestes das einzige perlprogramm was ich jemals bei mir auf dem rechner entzählen
würde die verwenden perl ja klar es ist aus dem gesichtspunkt sagt es massiv ja jetzt
fast alle ascii ist aber leider schlecht das könnte echt neue neue twitch copypasta werden
der ascii aquarium ist aber leider schlecht
so also erstmal wlan verbinden wi-fi wi-fi ach nee aha ja erstmal den wi-fi header
include auf wieder so ein so ein überbleibsel aus antiken zeiten gleich nur noch 50 prozent
view ja klar wenn 10 plus plus anfängt ist vorbei da die leute kein pop mehr drauf
wer hat wer hat da auch schon bock drauf oder kann man da kann man gar keinen bock drauf
haben wie wird der microcontroller programmiert über usb und danach über wlan also wi-fi
wir verbinden uns jetzt erstmal zum wlan erst einmal sicherstellen dass der nix altes
mehr leht disconnected sicherstellen und auto connect auto reconnect machen wir oft so also
sprich das ding sollte sich wieder verbinden wenn sie verbindung verwenden verliert allerdings
auto connect war mal auf falls weil ein speicher da auf dem flash keine wlan zugangsdaten
klingt jetzt irgendwie ein bisschen merkwürdig dass wir auto connect auf voll stellen und
auto reconnect auf true aber so war das halt
was was wir programmieren ja so richtig spezifisch nix ich versuche logs über websocket zu posten
ob das irgendwie funktioniert und ob ich ein ordentliches update was besser funktioniert
als das was ich gebastelt habe hin bekomme dass ich firmware update über wlan machen
kann ich weiß es gibt fertige sachen aber die haben ein paar probleme die fertigen sachen
erstens funktionieren die meisten sachen in die falsche richtung quasi dass der microcontroller
sich von einem server seine firmware abruft das ist gut wenn ich wenn ich den hersteller
bin der 20 millionen geräte auf der welt hat und einen öffentlichen server und will dass
die geräte sich von dort firmen was holen dann ist das gut ich will das anders ich will
eine neue firme machen und auf meinen controller pushen können das können die meisten custom
libraries nicht dazu kommt dass die meisten keine HTTPS können das ist nicht so wichtig
für microcontroller zeug und dass die meisten andere probleme haben die mir grad nicht einfallen
ist nicht so schwierig zumindest ich hab ja auch schon mal sowas in der richtung programmiert
dass man über ein formular auf einer webseite oder über einen karl aufruf machen jetzt
eine neue firme hochladen kann problem ist halt ich hab es ein bisschen verkackt ich
muss alles andere stoppen wenn ich den update vorgang anfange weil sonst gehts kann ich
kann ichs quasi so deadlocken also sprich wenn er irgendwas anderes macht während dem update
dann dann hängts und geht nie wieder aus und dann muss ich das strom resetten das ist
ziemlich ziemlich kacke wir verbinden uns jetzt aber erstmal zum wlan danach probieren
wir das mit dem mit dem websocket aus wo wir mal was loggen können also set auto reconnect
auf true so und dann sagen wir hier mal beginn so ssid password das hab ich in der anderen
datei gespeichert so und jetzt war magic jetzt gucken wir ob das ganze nehmen wir machen
eine schleife das ist ja noch wenig c++ das ist ja alles password liegt im autocomplete
ne jebaiten wir nicht wir gucken jetzt ob das wlan connected ist und solange der kram
nicht connected ist oh ich hab noch ne schöne spielerei die wir ausprobieren können ich
hab noch ne schöne ne schöne spielerei die wir ausprobieren können wir müssen auch
erstmal übrigens unsere unsere serielle schnitt stelle zum loggen einschalten mit
wahnsinnigen 9600 das ist default ansonsten müsste ich ein müsste ich mehr einstellen
aber das reicht zum loggen und jetzt gucken wir solange wlan nicht connected ist geben
wir erste mal nen punkt aus so und dann sleepen wir mal für 100 millisekunden und danach
sagen wir danach brinden wir mal die ip die der controller bekommen hat local ip dann
gucken wir mal ob das so weit funktioniert upload upload beim schauen ob der kram jetzt
tut und danach versuchen wir mal was was woops ah ich sollte vielleicht den controller auch
durchreichen zur vm ja alles gut mach mal exzellent was what the fuck
warum er erkennt er meinen controller nicht hat er doch ne hat er nicht wisst ihr was
wir machen den windows den windows style beim reboot so macht was wenn ich geht einfach
rebooten it ticknummer 1 ja ist echt so der zwitsch zuschauer 800 punkte gewaistet 3 380
so upload was warum installiert er da jetzt irgendwas restart ok ja mache ich darf ich
jetzt darf ich darf ich jetzt darf ich jetzt upload jetzt darf ich ok warum auch immer
wenn jetzt wenn jetzt zu wenn jetzt überall twitch chat punkte gewaistet oder was exzellent
chat high iq plays ich sehe schon wieder
guck mal ich kann meine eigenen emotes meine eigenen emotes verändern und posten
falls du die punkte weg iq chat schwachsinn so dann werde ich mal ein stellenbar twitch
gleich dass es ab jetzt 20.000 punkte kostet und natürlich bet ich euch oder denken die
leute 380 punkte und zack 20.000 punkte weg und dann und dann mache ich hier an das kam
ich habe 90 k fuck keine chance ich sehe schon so hat er sich jetzt eigentlich verbunden
habe ich überhaupt nicht zugeguckt hat er hat er sich jetzt zum wlan verbunden oder
nicht hat er sich jetzt zum wlan verbunden oder nicht ja hat er guck mal i p liegt 12
168 60 148 high iq leak soll jetzt habe ich eine idee jetzt jetzt jetzt jetzt passt
mir was was richtig was richtig nice ist und zwar immerhin punkte punkte sind langweilig
punkte sind sind sind doof ich muss jetzt mal kurz dass man das besser sieht ich gebe
jetzt mal hier ein schwachsinn password ein was wir jetzt sehen wird ist dass er sich
unendlich lang versucht zu connecten richtig krasser leak ja hardcore leak das habe ich
letztens schon im discord gepostet so punkt jetzt macht er immer punkte solange er sich
versucht zum wlan zu verbinden das ist natürlich langweilig deswegen ich habe ich habe da ich
habe da mal was vorbereitet was wir jetzt machen wir machen jetzt eine ordentliche lade
balken so und zwar eine lade balken der besteht aus einem pipe einem slash einem minus und
im backslash und jetzt ist die frage wie macht man das jetzt in c++ for each kann man sowas
kann man sowas machen näher achso das ist das ist das ist kein kein c++ string print
print f das wird jetzt mega advanced character i so und jetzt und jetzt haben wir jetzt haben
wir den übelst krassen lade balken hat der high iq lade balken haben wir jetzt oh ich
habe noch was vergessen ich habe was vergessen ihr werdet gleich sehen was ich vergessen
habe das funkt es funktioniert noch nicht so ganz ich sollte mal den upload speed ein
bisschen hoch stellen man sieht es funktioniert von der idee her funktioniert aber ich habe
eine entscheidende sache vergessen und zwar sowas hier was ist backslash b mir fällt
jetzt nur der ein was macht denn b guck mal das gibt hier irgendwie ein wabe ach ja das
zebaro schlägt gerade vor du kannst dir das gift energy mime spam lassen als lade balken
es ist unglaublich schwierig mit c++ emojis also strings mit emojis so dafür sowas hier
zu verwenden übrigens kommt mein lade balken funktioniert das ist mal massif iq lade balken
oder ich habe es nämlich mal versucht einen unicode wie auch immer er das intern encoded
unicode string zu verwenden und ich bin daran gescheitert ehrlich gesagt ich habe es nicht
hinbekommen weil man könnte ja man könnte ja auch deutlich advanced lade lade balken
machen ja also man könnte ja auch utf hier unicode progress bar da gibt es ja gibt es
ja zig zig varianten was man nehmen kann zum beispiel zum beispiel zum beispiel den da
habe ich mal probiert das problem ist dass das so nicht funktioniert logischerweise funktioniert
das so nicht weil das hier sieht jetzt zwar aus wie ein wie ein zeichen aber das ist ja
utf das ist unicode also weiß ich was es hier intern ist was verwendet java was verwendet
javascript intern utf 8 utf 16 bei c sharp ist utf 16 so das funktioniert nicht was
ich als nächstes probiert habe ist genau machen ein character wir können es ja mal
zusammen probieren wir können es ja mal zusammen probieren ich habe es nicht hinbekommen zumindest
nicht dass es auf arduino funktioniert also ich sage wenn man das hier nimmt funktioniert
schon mal gar nicht weil was er hier macht ist ja da nimmt ein zeichen und ein zeichen
ist nicht etwa sowas hier sondern ein byte gleich ein zeichen standardmäßig so und das
funktioniert nicht weil diese zeichen wahrscheinlich irgendwie keine 2 oder 3 byte sind wenn es
utf 8 ist oder ich weiß nicht was dieses zeichen aber definitiv mehr als ein byte man sieht
es ja auch hier schon das ist ein character array aus 56 zeichen obwohl es sichtbare sachen
eigentlich nur 1 2 3 4 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 also 28 sind ungefähr daran sieht man
schon dass es halt mehr braucht als als das und dementsprechend die unicode zeit klappen
wir auch nicht so aber ich habe keine ahnung wie man das schön macht wie man das in chat
wir machen das jetzt mal zusammen was soll ich machen wie kriegen wir das vielleicht
hin eventuell aber nur vielleicht diesem ding einen schönen utf 8 ladebalken zu basteln
das nächste was ich probiert habe ist genau genau mister leili das habe ich auch ausprobiert
richtig das ist das nächste das nächste habe ich das mit weh stringen versucht da weiß
ich aber schon gar noch wieder graben funktioniert hat ehrlich gesagt da musste man wie ging
das noch mal wobei das war doch richtig das ging doch so oder fack was mache ich denn
hier genau das habe ich nämlich auch probiert was hat er hier verschmerzen genau genau
weil es gibt es gibt u u und l ich habe keine ahnung was der unterschied dazu ist ich dachte
eigentlich dass u für anschein steht ist es aber gar nicht ist u für unicode vielleicht
aber für was ist die große so ein kleines u davor ich weiß nur dass man den fall l verwenden
muss der ja das stimmt das stimmt dass das geht mit l das habe ich nämlich schon mal
ausprobiert vorher so und wenn man jetzt denkt es funktioniert wird man auch sehen es funktioniert
nicht weil muss man warten bis er abgelaudet hat da spakt immer noch um das funktioniert
auch nicht und das war der punkt wo ich mir nicht mehr so ganz sicher war warum es nicht
funktioniert weil ein charakter ist ja im endeffekt jetzt ein w char was auch immer
ein w char ist aber wahrscheinlich kann das das print f hier an der stelle nicht vermute
ich mal deswegen muss man genau deswegen muss man w nee ach nee moment was muss man dafür
noch mal einbinden dass der kram funktioniert string nee stream was muss man dafür noch
mal einbinden aus stream aus stream ja ich kann jetzt hier plus plus sachen so gut merken
aus stream muss man dafür einbinden so und dann kann man sagen ww warum das ist auch
so eine sache die mich übelst an c++ triggert warum warum alles in der welt so was hässliches
um text auszugeben muss muss das muss das echt sein so und jetzt sind wir mal sind wir
mal so gut und machen noch komm wir machen kein jule ein wir upload uns einfach mal gucken
was passiert so und das ist das habe ich auch auf github gefunden nicht auf github auf
stack overflow gefunden und das ist was was theoretisch funktioniert ich bin jetzt nicht
so ganz sicher woran es liegt dass es nicht funktioniert entweder weil das einfach das
serial out nicht kann das wäre möglich das macht nämlich einfach gar nichts oder weil
oder weil die arduino standard library scheiße ist bzw die die die esp geschichte ich würde
sagen das probieren wir gleich noch mal aber vorher machen wir mal ein output der nicht
der nicht serial out ist weil es kann durchaus sein dass serial out das nicht kann printet
wie wc out überhaupt in den in den naja sie out macht es auf jeden fall guck wenn ich
hier sowas hier mache blub dann macht es das oder macht es das nicht ich ich will ich ich
habe ich die vermutung es macht das nein es macht es nicht okay ich habe nichts gesagt
es funktioniert es funktioniert doch es funktioniert habe ich nämlich schon mal ausprobiert es
funktioniert warum das jetzt so langsam ist weil ich das nicht flasche beziehungsweise
kein kein line ending dranmacht wenn ich leinen dranmacht dann geht das geht das schneller
das macht meine idee da gerade was ist das jetzt fall back the fuck btf ja jetzt funktioniert
c++ gremium big brain c++ verwendet sachen gerne doppelt und dreifach ich glaube und
ich bin mir da nicht so sicher und ich bin mir nicht sicher ob das stimmt was ich erzähle
das und und bedeutet glaube ich dass es eine referenz ist und dass es eine read only referenz
ist was ist das und und eine konstreferenz das heißt so oder das und und das eine und
ist dass es eine referenz ist und das ach was auch immer und und ist ein rw ist eine
rw reference ah yes alles klar äh wie flascht man eigentlich wie fief ah hier so oder so
erst mal vielleicht was macht das auto das auto ist eine kurzform für den typ hinschreiben
das ist ein bisschen was wie war in c sharp das funktioniert nicht wie ich mir das gedacht
habe muss ich da muss ich da was angeben bei standard flasch anscheinend was muss ich
da angeben überhaupt ist das kompliziert flasch output stream so ne ah yes excellent
mal ganz davon abgesehen dass es trotzdem nicht das macht was ich haben will ah ok ich
gebe zu wenn was weiß ergibt das sinn wenn was weiß ergibt das sinn aber schöne syntax
ist es trotzdem nicht
das heißt dass quasi eine referenz auf temporär ist ganz dumm und nicht 100 prozent richtig
ist ja vieles in c++ ist ganz dumm aber das funktioniert ist schön so und das dumme ist
dass das ganze mit wc out nicht funktioniert und ich denke mal das liegt unter anderem
daran dass mein serial kein kein utf was auch immer das intern für den coding ist was
ist das denn jetzt eigentlich ach nee ach nee ich vergaß das ist ja c++ das ist wahrscheinlich
implementierungs abhängig es ist mal 16 bit mal 8 bit oder mal 32 bit das bestimmt c++
weil bei c++ ist immer immer wenn das gremium keinen bock hat sich ihren eigenen mist im
detail auszudenken dann sagen sie implementierungs abhängig das ist immer geil oder wie was
hä nee implementierungs abhängig ok das funktioniert nicht so das das liegt bestimmt daran weil
es mein serial mein serial kann das wahrscheinlich nicht deswegen war jetzt mal weiter mit der
eigentlichen sache die ich vor hatte nämlich websocket verbindung deswegen war jetzt mal
eine websocket verbindung und gucken ob wir das darüber ausgeben können interessant wie
wir jetzt von interessant wie wir jetzt von wir wollen ein update mechanismus programmieren
zu wir machen den kommando zeilen spinner mit utf 8 gekommen sind mit unicode warum
sage ich immer utf 8 das ist eigentlich ganz einfach unicode ist da ist das ding was die
zeichen definiert utf 8 ist ein encoding also eine implementierung von unicode
so password so jetzt probieren wir erstmal bevor wir weiter machen dass wir jetzt auch
eine ordentliche ausgabe haben was was theoretisch unicode zeichnen kann weil ich bin mir ziemlich
sicher ein serial output kann das wahrscheinlich gar nicht skill killer verstehe ich auch nicht
utf 16 verwenden oftmals sachen die schon ein bisschen älter sind also ich weiß dass
dort net intern utf 16 verwendet sachen die relativ neu sind so was wie rust die verwenden
zum beispiel komplett utf 8 intern ja und utf 32 kann ich verstehen dass man das verwendet
es hat bestimmt in der verarbeitung seinen scham wenn man sich darauf verlassen kann
dass alles exakt gleich lang ist das ist ja bei utf 8 das problem utf 8 ist ja auch in
sofern rückwärts kompatibel zu ascii dass die erste dass das erste halbe weit das erste
weit das erste weit ist komplett komplett kompatibel zu ascii und danach ist es irgendwie
immer wenn ein eins am ende steht geht es weiter das ist bei utf acht ein bisschen ein
bisschen magic ich versuche jetzt mal eine websocket verbindung zu machen dann geht das
dann geht das einfacher und zwar was ich ganz gerne als webserver verwende ist das ding
das ist ziemlich praktisch weil es von haus aus asynchron ist installieren wir jetzt mal
das ist deswegen verwende ich hier auch immer die als idee ganz gerne diese plattform auch
geschichte hat den riesen vorteil gegenüber der arduino idee es ist eine ordentliche editor
mit ordentlichem autokomplete und alles und die integration mit github ist auch viel schöner
vielleicht es ist nicht tcp webserver braun vom christo gottkopf das ist bestimmt ein
komponent install excellent so da war jetzt mal ein beispiel in websocket beispiel gibt
sein websocket beispiel natürlich natürlich nicht websocket ich habe jetzt leider kein
projekt wo ich abgucken kann aber das sind nur zwei das ist alles schwach sind brauche
man alles nicht hier ja das brauche man das glaube ich das einzige was man braucht es
sind websocket auf diesem dings ne micropython mag ich nicht frag mich nicht warum vielleicht
weil ich es nie richtig ausprobiert habe kann auch sein ja websockets da excellent das braumer
zack essen webserver das war nämlich gar nicht so kompliziert warum geht warum geht
das jetzt nicht bild warum mag der nicht was hat er für schmerzen oder hat er einfach
nur die neue libraries und ich geladen huge huge musik ich muss es kann durchaus sein
dass es super toll ist mit micropython ich habe es einfach nur nicht großartig ausprobiert
wird das noch aktiv entwickelt ja vor fünf tagen cool muss ich mal ausprobieren so webserver
das haben wir alle schon genau das brauchen wir die zwei sachen die drei sachen brauchen
wir noch das war es dann läuft unser webserver den habe ich schon ein paar mal verwendet
da weiß ich dass der das der funktioniert so und jetzt haben wir eine websocket verbindung
jetzt brauchen wir bloß noch den händler und den händler muss man natürlich jeder
vor definieren weil wir sind ja in hardcore c++ da ist das halt noch so serial print so
ws message upload so jetzt sollten wir uns connecten können auf unseren esp mit websocket
wendler habe habe ich zu lang schon den wendler nicht mal gezeigt aber willst mal wieder sehen
das ist ein esp 32 das ist kein echter arduino das ist ein fake arduino
händler oder händler das habe ich gar nicht gesehen was war das ding für eine ip 60 60
100 149 oder so ne 148 ah yes excellent jeder ist auch im wlan ok gucken wir uns mal um
pons ws kett nee fack websocket kett wie ist das noch mal
ws kett websocket genau das brauche man fünf
kann man sich zu websockets verbinden und dann sehen wir gleich ob es funktioniert
gibst du den ganzen esp eine feste ip indirekt ich mache dhcp reservierung
ich mache ich mache dhcp reservierung was war das slash ws bäm wir haben eine verbindung
zack funktioniert easy websocket verbindung zum esp so und jetzt können wir mal probieren
ob der kram funktioniert wir schicken nämlich einfach alle 100 millisekunden das ist das
ist mit der library ist das wirklich easy wir schicken alle 100 millisekunden eine nachricht
ähm an alle äh nee warte mal wie ging das an alle hier genau print print all blub so
wir schicken alle 100 millisekunden nachricht an alle verbundenen websocket clients hast
du den esp als note mcu habe ich auch ja ich habe ein paar note mcu's und in neuer
dings habe ich habe ich die hier mr.
laily ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine ahnung weiß ich nicht wieder random zeugs kein kein
schimmer habe ich noch nicht mit beschäftigt ja aber wie gesagt neuesten habe ich habe
ich die hier die sind ein bisschen teurer aber die sind als super klein und passen überall
rein also bestes esp 32 bord auch super für batterie geeignet finde ich ist das beste
esp 32 bord wenn es was kosten darf die note mcu's sind natürlich deutlich deutlich billiger
wenn ja kannst du eine montage halterung dafür empfehlen boah nee ich habe ein drei ich
trug mir immer ein 3d zum zum so ein universal 3d case aus wo alles mögliche reinpasst mit
3d drucker und da wird es einfach reingeschmissen gut ist aber eine spezielle gute note mcu
halterung kann ich jetzt nicht sagen so guck wir kriegen unsere nachricht funktioniert
so dann gucken wir mal ob wir da drüber unseren unseren easy mode spinner hinkriegen guck mal
ob wir das ob wir das aber das der standard spinner ist ja kein kein großartiges problem
schleife spinner und dann print all er sind c und i und jetzt mal gucken ob das funktioniert
moin nivana hd guck mal ob jetzt auch jetzt unser stylischer lade balken auch per websocket
auf der konsole klappt eine sache müssen wir noch umstellen die nicht so ganz funktionieren
wird wahrscheinlich ja guck mal der macht nämlich immer das ruckelt leute das das sieht
jetzt es sieht zwar künstlericht wertvoll aus aber das ist nicht das was wir haben wollen
wir wollen nadeball haben da müssen wir null hinten angeben dass er nicht automatisch
nur leihnach jeder nachricht einfügt und jetzt haben wir quasi ein schöner schönen ausgabe von
unserem spinner über websocket nicht dass es jetzt in irgendeiner art und weise auch nur
annähernd sinnvoll wäre dass wir lade balken über websocket haben was passiert hier grad im
chrome ganz grob ich versuche grad wo habe ich wo habe ich denn mein das alles zugemacht das
alles zugemacht und zwar habe ich meine tür gegen sprech anlage mit einem esp 32 abgekradet
mit so einem bord das steckt jetzt quasi in der wandhalterung von der gegen sprech von dem
gegen sprech telefone und erkennt wenn jemand die klingel drückt und wenn jemand die klingel
drückt dann hängt da lieber ein tablet und da schaltet also wird das tablet eingeschaltet
und automatisch die kamera ansicht geöffnet von tor und hof wenn die klingel geht so und ich habe
eine sache echt verkackt und zwar ist das das update übers wlan ich habe ein paar esp verteilt
bei mir im haus und die haben alle so ein so ein echt schlecht programmierten wlan update von mir
der öfters mal abkackt und so sehr abkackt dass ich power cycle muss deswegen wollte ich mal das
wlan update ordentlich programmieren und aus irgendwelchen gründen sind wir gerade darüber
stehen geblieben wie macht man über websocket von dem esp 32 den lade balken frag mich nicht
wie man von updates zu einem zu einem lade balken über websockets gekommen sind aber wir haben jetzt
den lade balken über websockets gemacht mit dem esp 32 richtige richtige hacker mans
bis jetzt sehen wir nur lade balken für wifi connect ja so sieht es aus aber über websocket
sehen wir die lade balken schon mal websockets erklären was wie soll ich websockets erklären
so als großer javascript pro im prinzip eine bidirektionaler verbindung zwischen server und
dem client normalerweise ist es ja bei http so http ist erstens komplett stateless und auch
nur immer request response bezogen also sprich es gibt keinen keinen response vom server ohne
dass es ein request vom client gegeben hat das ist natürlich doof wenn man beispielsweise
einem client mitteilen möchte hey es gibt neue daten keine ahnung du hast eine wetterapp ja du
hast eine wetterapp und willst den client informieren dass neue wetterdaten da sind das funktioniert
über normales http schlecht weil du kannst natürlich so sachen machen wie im hintergrund
immer wieder pollen und anfragen gibt es neue wetterdaten gibt es neue wetterdaten gibt es
neue wetterdaten aber über websocket ist das ganze schöner gelöst da bauste nämlich einmal eine
verbindung auf und die bleibt dann quasi offen wird dann erst so ein stream aufgebaut wie bei
tcp ja das ist ja immer so http ist ja auch über tcp mit dem unterschied dass du die verbindung
bei websockets offen hältst also du machst du machst einen normalen http request und den
upgradest du dann also so ist es im protokoll steht das drinne den upgradest du dann zu einer
websocket verbindung ich glaube ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher wie das geht ich glaube du machst du
machst ein get mit speziellen optionen oder so und wenn der server das versteht dann upgrade
der normalen http request auf dem websocket verbindung und die geht halt in beide richtungen
da kann der server auch ungefragt sachen schicken das ist halt praktisch weil ansonsten müsstest du
alle alle paar sekunden pollen und fragen sind neue daten da sind neue daten da und es ist natürlich
super für chats für sachen mit echtzeit kommunikation oder zum beispiel wo es richtig gut ist für
fahrzeug tracking wenn du so eine map hast wenn du quasi auf dem server siehst wo die einzelnen
fahrzeuge sind und die schicken dir das und du zeigst es an und update ist das ja websockets
pollen pollen hat also hat nichts mit den polen zu tun und auch nichts mit pflanzen fortpflanzung
sondern heißt nichts anderes wie aber du weißt wahrscheinlich weil ich sehe hier öfters dass
man einfach öfters anfragt beim server oder bei irgendeiner gegenstelle ob es neue sachen gibt
oder oder bei an irgendeinem interface einfach guckt ob neue sachen da sind dass man nicht
benachrichtigt wird wenn neue sachen da sind sondern dass man immer selbst nachguckt ob neue
sachen da sind klassisch klassischerweise gab es die variante entweder man polled also sprich
man fragt permanent nach gibt es neue sachen oder man hat ein callback registriert der dann
aufgerufen wird wenn man wenn es neue sachen gibt exzellent so sieht es aus aber ist so eine
ständig offene websocket für mich ein sicherheits risiko habe ich mir ehrlich gesagt und die
gedanken drüber gemacht aber nachdem ja nur der server zu dem du absichtlich freiwillig eine
verbindung aufgebaut hast dir darüber was schicken kann wüsste ich jetzt nicht warum
du musst ja die du musst ja die websocket verbindung initiieren also du bist da klein
und sagst hallo server mach websocket verbindung auf das heißt du du sagst du willst das haben
und dann ist eigentlich dadurch ok unsicher genau wen juckt sicherheit hast du neues mikrofon
fragen mich viele heute ich habe ein bisschen kompressor settings eingeschaltet vor 23 streams
das ist eingebaut hier in in der in der schell von diesem in den zsh plugin keine ahnung
welches das ist so also weiter jetzt wir wollten jetzt ja gucken wir über websocket unseren
schönen unseren schönen lade balken mit utf acht zeichen hinbekommen so gucken wir mal also ich
hoffe die c++ pro sind noch da und jetzt mal was nicht print f kann man dafür nicht verwenden
weil print f brauche es ist kein dinger das ist dann immer nur ein byte wir machen einfach
mal print ne was fack wie schicken wir das denn jetzt an den meiner mein heute das schlechte
an als voll höre ich mich heute wirklich so viel anders an vielleicht habe ich nämlich
anderweitig noch irgendwelche settings verstellt wartet mal wie konnte man hier noch mal die
monitoring monitoring ausgabe anmachen irgendwie hier na so test
ne eigentlich höre ich mich doch genauso an
oder oder bin ich zu laut eingestellt es kann aussehen wir probieren wir probieren es mal
was wartet man wir probieren das mal aus aber gerade vor ist das unter windows wieder
aber ein bisschen leise so ist das ist das jetzt besser weil also sollte ich jetzt über
steuert gewesen sein dann dann sollte das jetzt auf keinen fall mehr so sein ist besser
weil die lautstärke dürfte keinen großen unterschied machen der kompressor sollte
das komprimieren da gibt es einen einfachen tritt ja schieß los aber eigentlich kann
kein großer unterschied zu vorher sein oder ist jetzt ein großer unterschied kann ich
hier links pausen ja wir kommen auf die links an jetzt ist natürlicher ok exzellent exzellent
natürlich exquisit vielleicht war ich auch einfach nur zu weit ich war ich auch einfach
nur zu weit weg sollte das jetzt hier dran machen kann hier irgendwie asmr stream mit
asmr so was auch immer so lassen wir den sound erstmal so so also wie
kann man jetzt hier ohne dieses ganze printf gedöns den kram ausgeben text text all was
ist text text warum hat er eigentlich was ist das eigentlich auch wieder für eine für
eine verkackte api ich mein text all haben wir binary all verstehe ich ja noch message
all text all message all und und print print f all da fack warum
was wird hier gemacht ich versuche gerade sp 32 beizubringen mein utf 8 auszugeben oder
mein unicode auszugeben aber das ist wahrscheinlich nicht so ach nee man braucht w print f das
kann das ding jetzt wieder nicht oder was ich bin verwirrt ok ok wir gucken uns jetzt
mal an die pros dazu sagen hier richtig der hexa der reverse pwner so hier hast du ein
beispiel für ein vector t mit remove index verwendet ok zeige mal ist das das ist nicht
terminus oder was ist das für ein font da kommt mir eh schon wie bekannt vor das ist
dings hier den kenne ich den hatte ich früher auch mal wie heißt er noch mal der kommt mir
übelst bekannt vor der font sf mono nie sf mono ist es nicht den hatte ich den hatte
ich früher nicht dann ist es was anderes so also sollte er jetzt nicht deine nachricht
eigentlich da jetzt ok also wie funktioniert easy vector ok das ist in den in rapper um
vector ja gut klar ja das ist dass ich dass ich dass ich den dass ich den vector irgendwie
rappen kann das ist klar dass es so kurz und knackig geht finde ich gut ich finde es aber
trotzdem bescheuert dass so was standardmäßig nicht drin ist weil ich meine die haben ja
in der standard lebe sau viel zeugs drin und da ist ja auch das ist ja auch nicht unsinnig
was da drin ist aber warum macht man das so eklig zu benutzen das verstehe ich nicht
hier kann man hier kann man dann arduino string verschicken ok kann man auch einfach nur
dann kann er sowas hier in den vettcher den vettcher kann ich auch eine sache die mir
persönlich als h plus plus mega auf den sack geht diese absolut grandiosen fehler meldungen
weil die jetzt gehen die ist und die ist noch ok ich meine man erkennt was sache ist noch
matching function call invalid konvert die die die versteht man noch die ist auch ok
die ist jetzt gar nicht so flamen würdig wie kriege ich dem dann jetzt verklickert dass
deren wie kriege ich dem jetzt verklickert dass dass ich den w string ausgeben will
überwegts websocket ich glaube für die unicode spinner wäre simpelste kpob ich probiere mal
ich bin da ja offen für also so meinst du hier ja aber geht das dann aber ok
zeige ich mal ja ich bin ich bin ich mal gespannt ob das funktioniert
was hat er für schmerzen
das ist jetzt ein standard string ok den können wir aber hier als c c things cast und dann
geht das wenn das jetzt wenn das jetzt geht bei sich mir in arsch er spiele mal gespannt
ob das funktioniert die mann was die mann linter moin picks all didn't happen was meinst
ich bin im moment ich muss mir ein arsch bei ist das sind das sind das ordentliche utwachzeichen
überhaupt
moment noch mehr was gerade es ziemlich safer bei meinen sachen das ist jetzt nicht auch
Das ist eine richtig gute Idee eigentlich, da hätte ich auch drauf kommen können, da
hätte ich auch drauf kommen können, man scheißt einfach drauf, dass Character Character ist,
man nimmt einfach ein Character als String, das sind ja zwar mehrere Bites, aber das
ist ja nicht unter der Haube egal, solang es das Ausgabegerät versteht, ja nice, das
funktioniert, exellent, exellent Leute, exellent, high IQ Poggers Chat, Wahnsinn, Wahnsinn,
der Chat, muss man da Zwischenkommas machen, ich habe jetzt nicht geguckt, da muss man
Zwischenkommas machen, hätten wir jetzt mal Vimbindings, dann würde das schneller gehen,
mit Vimbindings hätte man sowas richtig zackig erledigt, dann würde man es nämlich einfach
den hier machen, so und dann drückt man Punkt für Wiederholen und dann wäre es drin, aber
wir haben keine Vimbindings, ich weiß, dass wir Vimbindings für Visual Studio Code anmachen
könnten, aber Vimbindings in Visual Studio Code sind insofern blöd, weil sie laggen,
die sind nicht so zackig, ich bin mal gespannt, kannst du Serial Output auch, kannst du Serial
Output auch, kannst du Serial Output auch, 3D, Vim 3D, der Josen ist mal wieder am Start,
Josen spielst du Valorant, Valorant, Valorant, Valorant, Valorant, oh jetzt, jetzt mal gucken,
sogar, sogar die serielle Ausgabe kann das, nice, guckt euch mal an hier, guckt euch mal
an, wie gut das funktioniert, Massive Pog, Valorant, Valorant, Valorant, Huge Ladebalken
Skills, ja, wie wir von HTTP Update auf Ladebalken gekommen sind, ist exzellent, da ist ein Zeichen
doppelt, OMFG, Anzeige ist raus, ja alles klar Sebaro, ja ich habe es nur eine Woche
nicht gesehen, sonst hätte ich das viel früher bezahlt, so jetzt müssen wir natürlich auch
dafür sorgen, dass es ein richtig echter, ein richtig echter nicer Ladebalken wird und
zwar, sagen wir da jetzt, brinnt an alle, machen erstmal, springen wir zurück und dann,
was ist es, $s für den String und dann uploaden wir das ganze und jetzt sollte der Ladebalken
richtig, richtig huge sein, what, what, ach nee der Ladebalken mit zurücksetzen funktioniert
natürlich nicht, das ist natürlich, oh da müssen wir unsere Ladebalken Skills noch
ein bisschen erweitern, wir müssen den Ladebalken machen und dann, und dann, und dann müssen
wir resetten, resetten wenn der Ladebalken am Ende ist, oh Poggers, ja jetzt wird, weil
so sieht der Ladebalken kacke aus, wie letztes hoch, hängt das per USB dran, ja, ich müsste
übrigens mal die Übertragungsrate ein bisschen hoch stellen, die ist ein bisschen, ein bisschen
langsam, oh nee, ey cool, das gefällt mir richtig gut, das gefällt mir mal richtig
gut, guck mal hier, da geht mir richtig einer ab bei dem Ladebalken, ja, das ist doch nice,
da kann jetzt keiner sagen, wir hätten nicht einen schönen Ladebalken, was wird dann
das wenn es fertig ist, frag nicht, sinnlose, eigentlich komplett nicht zielführende Spielereien
mit Text Ladebalken, total für'n Arsch eigentlich, die ursprüngliche Sache war, ich wollte,
ich wollte meine ganzen Controller, die ich im Haus hab, mal ordentlich updaten können
über WLAN und ne, und ne Ausgabe machen und, und, und loggen können über Websocket, dass
ich mitbekomme, was die Dinger machen, mach mal nen TCP-Dump drauf, was da passiert,
kann ich machen, aber was erhoffst du dir davon, dass du bei TCP-Dump was siehst, das
ist ne Websocket Vermittlung, das heißt, es wird jede Menge TCP-Traffic sein, den man
sich danach angucken kann, eben, wir können mal, wir können mal reingucken, das ist glaub
ich wirklich ganz interessant, wir gucken mal kurz rein, zwar nicht mit Wireshark, sondern
mit, nicht mit TCP-Dump, sondern mit Wireshark, weil mit nem TCP-Dump man sich wahrscheinlich,
warum eigentlich nicht MQTT, weil man Ladebalken nicht über MQTT verschickt, sondern Statusnachrichten
über MQTT verschickt, so, machen wir mal auf, ich, wir machen das Ganze mal über Wireshark,
Wireshark, so, wir sollen vielleicht mal als Route, als Route starten, das ist tatsächlich
mal ganz interessant, wir können uns das Ganze mal angucken über Wireshark, ein bisschen
doof jetzt über Wireshark, weil ich auch mein Host-Traffic wahrscheinlich mitschneide,
dürfte ganz schön viel sein, guckt euch das mal an, ey, so, stopp, also RTMP ist alles,
ist alles schonmal, alles schonmal Dings hier, alles schonmal Twitch, ist alles schonmal
für'n Arsch, d.h. wir müssen das Ganze jetzt filtern, IP, IP, IP, IP, 168.60, 148 war's
glaube ich, sehr schön, so, so kann man Netzwerk-Traffic untersuchen, d.h. jetzt haben wir den ganzen
Traffic, der von mir zu meinem ESP geht, Stream-Key liegt, oh, fuck, oh, oh, und IP liegt auch
noch, hei, hei, hei, hei, hei, RIP, Leute, was sagst du eigentlich zum Valorant-Anti-Cheat-Rama,
da wollte ich auch was zu sagen, da wollte ich ein Video zu machen, ich, ich finde es
auf der einen Seite gerechtfertigt, dadurch, dass es halt nicht der vertrauenswürdigste
Anbieter ist aus China und das Ding schon weitreichende Berechtigung im System hat,
auf der anderen Seite würde ich sagen, erstens viele Leute ist es scheißegal, sie sind
bei weitem nicht die einzigen, die Dinge machen, es gab schon Anti-Cheat-Software, die da
eine Steam-Chats mitgelesen hat, ich mein, das macht's nicht wirklich besser, aber das
ist zumindest gewisserweise akzeptiert, merkwiederweise von vielen Leuten und man wird ohnehin nicht
drumherum kommen, die werden nicht einfach von heute auf morgen sagen, nee, wir machen
das anders.
So Leute, hier haben wir unsere TCP-Verbindung zwischen dem, ähm, können wir unserem TCP-Stream
followen und wenn wir Glück haben, dürften wir da irgendwo unsere Zeichen drin sehen,
aber nachdem's UTF-8-Zeichen sind, sehen wir die wahrscheinlich eher, eher schlecht da
drinnen.
Äh, die Code, oh, wie ging das nochmal, fuck, ich hab schon, oh, ich verwende das so selten,
man konnte sich doch hier so ein schön, so ein schöne Text, Text, ähm, anzeichnen lassen
aus aller Pakete, war das die Code, nee, nee, nee, nee, ah nee, es ist schon auf, es ist
schon auf, ich hab bloß das Ding im Fullscreen gehabt, ja, so, das sind unsere, das sind
unsere, ähm, Messages, die wir schicken, wahrscheinlich hat das Ding Probleme mit UTF-8-Zeichen,
denk ich mal, beziehungsweise, ah hier, UTF-8, aha, da ist er, guckt hier, da ist unser Ladebalken,
seht ihr ihn, da haben wir mitgeschnitten, plus noch ein paar, plus noch ein paar, ähm,
Zeichen und Steuerdinger von, von Websockets, tja, so, so kann man das machen mit Wireshark,
ähm, mit TCP-Dump kann man das in der Form nicht machen, aber, aber, ähm, man kann mit
TCP-Dump mitschneiden in einem Format, was nachher mit Wireshark man sich angucken kann,
so viel Valorant ausgesprochen, ok, das hören wir uns jetzt an, das hören wir uns so an,
Moment, ich brauch den Link, Moment, Copy, Link, Sharon, excellent, hab ich zu leise,
kann das sein, ne, ich hab volle Pulle, ok, oh, machen wir mal unter, ach nee, machen
wir mal, machen wir mal unter, unter Windows, wie, wie, wie konnte man den Kram nochmal
kopieren, äh, Copy Address, was, Valorant, Valorant, Valorant, Valorant, ok, Valorant,
nicht Valorant, Valorant, also mit Doppel L quasi, Valorant, Valorant, aber, aber kann
die auch, aber kann die auch, Valorant, kann man das hier ändern, ich will, ich will das
ändern, kann man was reinschreiben, Edit, Edit, wie, wie kann man das editieren, ah,
ja, ja, und wie spricht man das jetzt aus, alles klar, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ja, ja, ja, ja, wir können
Pause dazwischen machen soll, Punkt dazwischen, Speed A, Minus, Minus 6, die spricht sich
langsamer aus, die machen es einfach nur Post-Processing langsamer, ne das quält man nicht, so was haben
wir hier noch zu bieten, Ryan, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah,
u Bantu, einem normaler Speed u Bantu.
Ah, ja, auf Deutsch, auf Deutsch, kann das Deutsch, ah, hier, wir nehmen mal Reiner,
bärter bärter oder
Klaus
Grüß dich box habe eine frage an frag schieß los die bunt was
die bunt
bunt
Kommt aus dem osten der klaus ist die bunt. Du die bunt
Peter
bunt
Bunt, du
Jetzt oder was was was sagt alberto
Ubuntu
Oja dem oja sie brauer brauer
aller
Übank ü. Oh ja exzellent
Übank ü
So sehen was dabei
Erich
Ubuntu die aussprache von den schweden ist am besten
Ubuntu noch so noch so ungefähr
Ab am nächsten dran die französische kanada
officially
Ubuntu
immer
Schn Sur
alles klar jetzt wissen wir auch wie man velorant ausspricht velorant ok kann ich bitte kein
im leben nicht merken velorant ok der lordkiller der lordkiller fragt also was fragt der lordkiller
habe vor zwei tagen mein system neu aufgesetzt und aber über ein altes trüber installiert ok
nun habe ich keine rechte mehr wenn ich die festplatte formatiere und dann neu installiere
habe ich ja aber aber hast du nicht daten drauf die du brauchst du könntest zum beispiel wenn
du daten retten musst könntest du den linux auf usb sing machen und davon booten man kann aber
sich garantiert auch unter windows habe ich aber keine ahnung von man kann sich garantiert auch
irgendwie unter windows als admin anmelden und sich wieder rechte geben garantiert und der linux
wäre das einfach ja sudo c h mod fertig aber wenn du die festplatte komplett platt
machst und windows komplett neu installiert dann hast du auch wieder rechte dann ist ja von den
alten nichts mehr übrig aber ich wäre vorsichtig weil ich meine verlierst ja alles was auf der
platte ist was haben die sich eigentlich beim firefox gelacht dass die neue url bar jetzt
und so ein fenster ist was da nach außen poppt wozu das macht kein anderes textdoc also kein
anderes input macht das in firefox nur die url bar wozu eigentlich was dein windows startet auch
laut bios im windows boot manager und nicht uefi modus was ach so ja das egal ich meine ich würde
kein bios boot mehr unbedingt machen heute nicht dass es einen großen unterschied macht ich mache
eigentlich nur noch uefi boot aber wenn du das wenn du das so so letztes wie bios boot hast es
ist auch nicht schlimm die wollten wieder chrome kopieren wieso macht chrome das auch
ja so um aber aber viel aber chrome macht das viel viel dezenter als firefox rückwärts
waren aber hier ist das richtig ich meine hier geht das einfach nur blauer raum drum rum und
hier poppt das erst mal zwei meter raus ja ja cooper es ist immer noch armselig der stand
vor allem unter linux was hardware decoding angeht sie sind ja mittlerweile dran aber gut
funktionieren tut das bei weitem noch nicht das dauert bestimmt noch ein jahr bis das halbwegs
funktioniert du kannst das mit der bar raus machen ok das ja ich dachte mir dass man das
irgendwie raus machen kann aber ich frag mich halt warum also sie haben sich irgendwas bei
gedacht ich würde interessieren was sie sich dabei gedacht haben ja wenn du alle deine
daten gesichert hast dann kannst du auch komplette winnaus neue installation machen
dann hast du auf jeden fall alle rechte wieder weil dann ist ja alles weg
dann noch über user styles ja da sind sie ja in firefox ganz groß mittlerweile drin
alte sachen zu deaktivieren was ich überhaupt nicht verstehe also wenn wenn firefox eine
sache früher ausgezeichnet hat und was für mich auch bis heute im endeffekt aber heute
schon bei weitem nicht mehr so viel der riesen vorteil von firefox war ist dass die plugins
schon immer umfangreicher und mehr machen konnten als in chrome beziehungsweise die
besten plugins gab es nun mal für firefox ursprünglich so allerdings haben die jetzt
so viel entfernt in firefox und so viel einschränkung vorgenommen für plugins dass es gar nicht
mehr der fall ist also die sind da mittlerweile ganz groß drin dinger zu entfernen und ich
muss ehrlich sagen mittlerweile schwindet der vorteil auch für technisch interessierte
leute gegenüber chrome ja klar sicherheitsgründe logisch natürlich dass sie das einfach nicht
einfach sich heute morgen aufgewacht sind aber das war halt das was firefox für mich
ausgezeichnet hat was braucht man überhaupt no script zum beispiel das alte no script
ich weiß nicht ob sie es bisher wieder so gut hingekriegt haben wie das alte no script
no script ging eine weile schlicht und ergreifend nicht richtig nach firefox was waren das 60
oder so und no script war das wichtigste plugin und das beste plugin nach wie vor für firefox
jetzt kann sein dass es mittlerweile halbwegs läuft mich würde mal interessieren ob es
alle funktionen vom alten no script hat aber bei der umstellung wurde das wurde ihre optionen
wurde quasi die plugins plugins eingeschränkt haben da lief schlicht da lief no script
einfach nicht und ich würde mal davon ausgehen dass man immer noch nicht so viele sachen
im neuen no script machen kann wie im alten no script no script heißt ja nicht dass du
javascript ausschaltest sondern nur dass du es freigeben musst auf der seite und ich
meine für die meisten seiten die man so verwendet konnte man das ja einfach freischalten da
hast du ein paar mal hast mal einen monat lang gesurft und geguckt und freigegeben und gut
war also eine sache die mir immer noch nach wie vor in firefox besser gefällt ist die
suchleiste also wenn ich hier zum beispiel das doch keine stack overflow der findet schlicht
und ergreifend mehr als chrome chrome hat so eine eigene so eine eigene logik was es
hier anzeigt firefox hat eine suche über die komplette history alle bookmarks und und
ja das war es history bookmarks was man so offen hatte das heißt ich habe schon so oft
in firefox sachen gefunden einfach nur weil ich danach gesucht habe in meiner history
und mein bookmarks die ich den chrome nie gefunden hätte dafür fehlen gerade bei rotenet
eine sache die mir zum beispiel fehlt in firefox die ich ein bisschen oder vielleicht
gibt es plugins dass man in firefox keine ordentliche mobile anzeige machen kann mit
touch input es gibt zwar diese touch input simuliergeschichte weiß gar nicht mehr wo
die jetzt war aber die funktioniert nicht richtig wie man schon sieht einfaches touch
scrollen funktioniert schon nicht die ist in chrome besser die sind besser es ist nicht
so wild ich weil man kann es einfach auf seinem auf seinem faunern aufmachen ja aber also
ja es wäre schon wäre schon angenehmer leute wir haben heute nicht wirklich was gemacht
ne drei stunden wir haben wir haben wir haben es geschafft nachdem ich eineinhalb stunden
geschwätzt habe haben wir es geschafft einen krassen lade balken zu machen über websockets
wahnsinn huge eine sache die in firefox auch noch drin ist diese in chrome meiner meinung
nach zumindest nicht gibt sind die pfister password manager also der password manager
mit master password chrome hat kein master password
benutzen also ich habe den früher ziemlich oft benutzt den password manager in firefox
gerade mit master password gut also wir haben zwei wichtige sachen gelernt erstens wie man
easy websockets macht auf dem esp 32 und wie man eine unicode progress bar macht jawoll
chrome nutzt den windows nutze als master password ja gut das bringt ja nicht wirklich viel oder
dann lieber custom password also sprich wenn du dir irgendwas eingefangen hast dann läuft
es ja unter deinem user und dann kann er auch einfach chrome sachen lesen von firefox wenn
der zu ist und nicht entsperrt dann musst du immer noch ein custom password wissen
ach so ist das echt ach interessant ok ich wollte übrigens auch mal ein video machen
irgendwie die fünf besten chrome tips könnte euch auch dran erinnern
aber dafür habe ich einen schönen ladebalken guckt ihn euch an leute guckt ihn euch an
guckt ihn euch an den ladebalken oder ist er nicht nice ist es ein absolut
huge ladebalken ruckelt übrigens fällt euch das auf der leckt der leckt der ladebalken
warum leckt der ladebalken jetzt hängt er komplett
ich denke mal das liegt an websog und näher oh meine sp ist gecrasht man ks
warum ist mein sp von publik ladebalken gecrasht es ist ein ladebalken
warum kreischt der sp von ladebalken das kann sich den ernst sein oder
ich denke ich kann auch nicht mal großartig misst programmieren oder der weckt das
räumt sich doch nach dem loopdurchlauf eh wieder automatisch auf wobei das hier
brauchen wir übrigens gar nicht wir können den spinner können spinner auch obei nee wir
machen noch eh eine endlosschleife drin wir machen doch eh eine endlosschleife drin kann
das sein dass der rumspackt weil die loop weil die arduino loop nicht durchläuft das könnte
sein oder weil die weil die arduino loop nicht durchläuft der macht bestimmt irgendwas bei
jedem complete von dieser loop oder dadurch dass ich eine endlosschleife drinne gebaut
hat mag er das bestimmt nicht was für pc teil hast du denn verbaut das hier an 8700 k
noch tourlüfter mittlerweile sind 32 gigabyte ram ein mainboard mit einer 10 g karte das war
damals weiß nicht warum ich hätte einfach eine pc karte machen können für 14 g netzwerk 500
g ssd nr 5 als gehäuse und 1080 ti als grafikkarte da wird man dann abgreif ich hab schon war schon
öfters dabei zu sagen ich muss mal upgraden ja aber es hat sich nie gelohnt es hat sich nie
es hat sich nie richtig gelohnt ich war schon kurz davor mir den ryzen 3050 zu kaufen 3050 x
jetzt probieren wir was ich als c++ hater wir machen jetzt mal eine eine eine klasse für
für meinen spinner big brain class wird das hier alles in line zack vector jawoll so
haben wir jetzt hier publik publik wo aber wir sind jetzt nicht in sich ab wollte und
keine andere kann spinn nehmen wir den kram standard string zurück in position position null so
und if das aber jetzt wenn meine position größer größer gleich der nennt ist es length
wie nenne ich den kram immer size size ist dann setzen wir die position wieder auf null zurück
und sonst return spinner pass mal gucken ob das funktioniert weil spritzer aus den fingern
saugt hab nur und nun können wir das umbauen haben wir zumindest schon mal schön lade balken
jetzt funktioniert ob es weniger ruckelt das beste ist es binnt ja gar nicht mal naja
ist es ist was macht es denn es bin nicht sondern es wie nennt man das es fluktuiert
es fährt hoch und runter so mal gucken es leckt immer noch warum leckten das so es pulsiert
genau warum warum leckten das so das gefällt mir nicht mein lade balken leckt das kann
man ein fapping lade balken was das letzte woran ich denken würde bei so einem komischen
lade balken ist das ja aber der twitch chat natürlich nicht der chat wieder ich fürchte
wir werden mit update nicht weit kommen es werden wir irgendwann anders machen ich hab
hunger ich muss was essen zugucken acht monate dankeschön ich habe hunger und ich bin müde
und ich hab keinen bock auf z plus plus und und wir haben immerhin den lade balken programmiert
was soll man wollen wir essen stream machen ich kann mir gleich was ja kommen wir kommen
wir können eine runde wir können runde videos gucken
was haben denn hier was hat denn hier unser kokona
whip i roasts for cheap korona roasts bacon cheese beer bread
das können wir uns gleich angucken ich gehe mir mal erstmals zu essen holen leute in der
zwischenzeit könnt ihr meinen lade balken angucken und unten drunter das ascii aquarium
ich bin in drei vier minuten wieder da ich hol mal kurz was zu essen
was
Ich bin jetzt schon nach dreieinhalb Stunden übelst müde.
Also ich habe hier jetzt vom Bäcker so ein Pizzabrötchen oder sowas das ist,
so ein Pizzabing. Ist keine echte Pizza, ist ein Brötchen,
aber sieht aus wie Pizza. Dann ein bisschen Käse und noch ein Stückchen Toastbrot mit
Milka drauf. So, das werde ich jetzt mal futtern. Pepe, Pepe fat, genau. Pepe sick. Gucken wir
uns mal ein Video an. Und ich büte mich mal zwischendurch kurz, wenn ich was futter,
weil ich will euch nicht gar so sehr ins Ohr schmatzen. Toastbrot mit Milka drauf,
ja warum nicht. Bisschen Süßkram, ist nicht verkehrt. Laut genug.
Wir brauchen alles was ungesundes. Irgendwie ist der Bart unscharf.
Also du hast ein Toastbrot mit einer Tafel Schokolade drauf.
Nee, keiner Tafel mit ein paar Stückchen von. Aber im Prinzip ja. Ah, excellent.
Das ist aber nicht der Typ, der sonst immer kocht. Normalerweise kocht doch immer der mit dem grauen Bart.
Ich finde es ja immer schon geil, wie die alles mit dem Messer und der Maräte machen mussten.
Da gibt es nicht Löffel und sowas, da wird alles mit dem Messer gemacht. Hell yeah.
Ich mag kein Bier. Mein favorite Bier ist kein Bier.
Was läuft hier plötzlich? Ich wollte eigentlich aufgehen, weil ich Hunger habe. Aber ich habe
kein Kaffee. Ich kann jetzt auch essen. Wir gucken uns einfach dabei bei Essen Videos an.
Trinkst du eigentlich Alkohol selten?
Ah, yes, Bacon. Kennt ihr immer noch Epic Meal Time von früher? Bacon Strips, Bacon Strips,
Bacon Strips, Bacon Strips. Die haben mal zwischenzeitlich aufgehört und sind jetzt übelst lame.
Ah ja, Mr. and Lady, das ist gut zu wissen, ja. Vom Essen zurück wieder Hunger, ja. Ich
glaube, das schmeckt auch übelst geil, wenn man nicht unbedingt gerade Veganer ist.
Es wäre ja einfacher zu mixen, wenn man dafür einfach einen Löffel nehmen würde anstatt
das Messer. Dann müssten wir auch nicht eine halbe Stunde mixen, sondern würde ein paar
mal durchrühren und gut werden. Aber ich glaube, das ist einfach nicht Pit-Boy-Style
genug, wenn man das mit einem Löffel macht.
Serious Max sagt gerade, warte, das wird Brot. Ich glaube ja, das heißt Brot, aber
da kommt wahrscheinlich von der Konsistenz ein bisschen sowas wie Lasagne raus, könnte
ich mir vorstellen. Moin, D-J-S-W-77 oder Jesus. Ja, die hat noch mal ein Krokodil.
Das ist aber nicht genug Social Distance hier. Was ist mit denen los?
Naja, das ist wirklich Brot. Ich habe gedacht, da kommt von Konsistenz ja sowas wie Lasagne
raus, aber das sieht wirklich aus eher wie Brot. Na komm, das hätte doch auch mal ein
bisschen schöner zeigen können, oder? Das hätte doch mal ein bisschen schöner zeigen
können, er erkennt so gar nichts. Ah, da gucken wir uns lieber RIP-EYE-ROSES
auf dem Pit-Boy-Style. Ah, ja, ja, ja, guck dir das an.
Welcome to BBQPitBoys.com, today we are going to show you how to save up to 50% on your
RIP-EYE-ROSES at the Pit, and it's real easy to do.
Das ist nicht der originale BBQ Pit-Boy, den will ich nicht gucken. Ich will den richtig
echten Hardcore-BBQ-Meat-BBQ-Pit-Boy gucken. Dener, dener mit dem weißen Harnelchen. Genau,
weißt du gar nicht, ob was ist. Wie? Gemüse? Was ist da los? Wo hast du denn deine Tiny
Pico's gekauft? Ähm, sag ich dir. Ich hab mir den Link von der offiziellen Seite rausgesucht.
Ähm, ich hab die gekauft, ich glaube hier. Ich kanns dir gleich sagen, ich muss mir
das nochmal angucken. Ich glaube hier. Genau, Amazon war zu teuer. Amazon war zu teuer,
das hab ich nicht eingesehen, für einen ESP32 35 Euro zu bezahlen. Wohingegen es einen
NodeMCU ESP32 von Aliexpress für 5 Euro gibt. Hier, hier hab ich die bestellt, oder? Genau,
für 20, für 20 Dollar. Für 20 Dollar hab ich die bestellt. Also wahrscheinlich hab
ich die entweder im offiziellen Shop bestellt oder bei denen. Da wo es 20 Dollar gekostet
ist, ich meine es ist immerhin noch dreimal mehr als einen Aliexpress. Bei Aliexpress gibt
es die, das bezweifle ich, dass es die bei Aliexpress so günstig gibt. Vielleicht haben
die es aber bei Aliexpress auch schon nachgebaut, das wundert mich natürlich nicht. Ne, den
gibt es nicht bei Aliexpress. Hätte mir jetzt auch echt gewundert, wenn es den bei Aliexpress
gibt. Du kriegst bei Aliexpress für 5, 6 Euro einen ESP32. Ja, wahrscheinlich gibt
sie demnächst billig aus China. Bei einem von denen hab ich gekauft. Wo steht Australia?
Ne, das wird nicht aus Australia geschippt. Die haben, das kam relativ schnell, es kam
relativ schnell an, muss ich sagen. Ich hab da drauf, keine Ahnung, 5, 6 Tage gewartet
und dann war es da. Guck mal mal. Chips from? Keine Ahnung, also es ging schnell. Wozu ist
der gut? Das ist ein ESP32-Microcontroller, der besonders klein ist. Das ist so ein halber
Daumen lang. Das heißt, der passt auch wunderbar in die Wand unter irgendeine Dose oder so.
Weiterfuttern, ich habe kaum was gegessen bisher. Will er jetzt hier das Steak erstmal vermessen?
Will er mit dem Schäler die Butter?
Der Hintergrund ist Greenscreen, oder? Guckt euch den Hintergrund an, das ist definitiv
Greenscreen.
Es wird hart, es wird hart, also tritt es mit Respekt. Perfekt. Oh Mann, wirst du mich verraten?
Ah, hier ist alles schön Butter drauf.
Schön Butter drunter schmieren, jawoll.
Wie er das immer betonen muss.
Was da drauf ist? Käse und Barbecue-Sauce. Tribble.
Aber Lord hilft ihm da jetzt nicht, weil er hat beim Thema Lord Sinn, dass mein Nachbar
der Meinung ist, Corona ist eine Strafe. Gott, das habe ich euch schon erzählt, oder?
Wie viel will er noch, soll er noch drauf.
Oh, Igil Sebarro, Alter. Ich will gerade half essen.
Was isst du gerade, so ein Pizza-Brötchen-Verbäcker?
Was kommt jetzt? Chili? Chili-Paste, oder was?
Was geht gerade mit dem Kommentator ab?
Das braucht einen richtig ordentlich verbrannten Rand, jawoll.
Ich habe auch gehört, dass es gut ist, erst mal abzulegen.
Das ist Diät-Food.
Das sieht aber gut aus, kann man nicht sagen.
So Leute, jetzt haben wir genug Grill-Videos geguckt, ich habe noch ein bisschen was zu
futtern da. Macht mal einen guten Vorschlag für ein anderes Essens-Channel, da gucken
wir uns noch ein anderes Essens-Video an. Wir müssen ja nicht immer Barbecue Pit Boys
gucken.
Almanac Kitchen, was? Was? Ice-Cream-Rolls, what the fuck?
Was ist das? Ich ahne, ich ahne, ich ahne Schlimmes.
Was gibt das? Will er nicht das grüne abmachen? Ja, das war jetzt wenig ASMR, voller Lautstärke.
How to basic, den können wir gleich noch gucken. Es wäre deutlich sinnvoller gewesen, hätte
man das grüne Zeug vorher ausgerissen, anstatt das so zu tun. Das ist nicht sonderlich optimist.
Um nicht zu sagen, es ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn. Und dann saut es auch noch rum. Das
ist beinahe ein Deutscher, es macht keinen Unterschied. Ich bin trotzdem unsinnig. 8,1
Millionen, boah. Na, habe ich in zwei Wochen auch, easy.
Was genau passiert da eigentlich? Ist das, ist das, ist, ist, kühlt das?
Boah, das ist ja, jetzt kommt das ASMR-Klister. Guck mal da, ein Ployeti da stehen. Ein, ein
nice, ein nice Mikrofon. Wow. Jetzt, jetzt will er es wissen. MonkaS Massaka, Alter.
Wie darf? Man hätte es vorher einfach schneiden können.
Also gut sieht das gerade nicht aus, aber wahrscheinlich sieht es am Ende gut aus.
Das habe ich schon mal gegessen, genau. Montag, Montag dürfen die Eisdielen wieder aufmachen.
Edward Spachtelhens. Brauche ich in Österreich nicht? Ja gut, da kann ich nichts zu sagen.
Boah, das sieht übelst abartig aus. Und das sieht nicht besser aus mit der Zeit.
Warte ab, okay. Ich glaube auch, vielleicht ist das nicht sonderlich repräsentativ, vielleicht
sind die anderen Sachen wirklich besser. Aber ich warte ab. Okay, wenn der Chat sagt,
ich soll abwarten, dann warte ich ab. Ich habe ja noch was zu essen.
Boah, Starback, Alter. MonkaS. Das Ding hat bestimmt einen netten Energieverbrauch, dieser
Kühler, den er da hat. Mit 8 Millionen Subs kann ich das leisten.
Okay, das sieht immer ganz eklig aus.
Boah, jetzt wird er schon draufgespritzt.
Das stimmt.
ja wir haben es verstanden
like comment subscribe
ich war es nicht
wahrscheinlich schmeckt nicht so schlecht weiß ich ob es gut schmeckt wahrscheinlich
schmeckt ganz okay aber es sieht irgendwie nicht so aus als nicht so für mich sieht aus
wie rinde stimmt schon irgendwie aber ich glaube das video ist nicht sondern nicht repräsentativ
da hat bestimmt der hat bestimmt deutlich sebaro du sagst doch du guckst das öfters was was ist
davon jetzt was ist das beste video schau mausklickt video
wie geht das überhaupt monste energie orea ice cream nutella rolls
oreo macht er gerne man hätte auch einfach einen löffel nehmen können
metal auf metal schlagen ist für mich auch der beste asmr sound die barbie
cupid boys hätten dafür ihre marete genommen
jetzt kann er über takten gleich noch einen ordentlichen lüfter drauf
dann pappt das so noch tour lüfter der haftet bestimmt gut
das kommt uns jetzt nicht an
den videos cool finde den kannst du jetzt kannst du auch kompletten youtube noobs
zeigen und die sind davon immer so richtig fertig danach die denke ich ach ja der macht
jetzt halt eine salze und gleich schmeißt er irgendwelche eierhomme oder so und steckt
sein knie in hähnchen und sowas der tüber ist auch echt da übelst nachschaden der hat
auch jemanden hähnchen und dann haut das irgendwie ein ei immer aufs knie
aber wirklich nackt ist keine ahnung er hat zumindest keine hose an so weit man das sieht
er jetzt soll Oscar
mir geht es aber nicht ich kenne die videos ja ich weiß ja was auf einen zukommt aber
Ich kann ja bei fast allem essen und ich kann ich ja auch bei essen, aber es muss nicht sein. Ja es muss es muss nicht sein
Ist ja das, das ist ja doch im Leben nicht. Oh Mann. So Leute ich bin fertig mit dem Essen. Na gut.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht ob wir noch wirklich weitermachen. Mein Ladebalken ist übrigens immer noch am laden wie ihr seht. Der funktioniert jetzt.
Kannst du Visual Studio empfehlen? Ja. You suck at cocking. Nein, cooking. Ich kann noch nicht weiter programmieren. Das macht mein Hirn gerade nicht.
Ich kann nicht mit nach dreieinhalb stunden streben. Warum kannst du das empfehlen? Was macht das plus? Also redest du jetzt von Visual Studio und von Visual Studio Code.
Aber ich kann beides empfehlen. Visual Studio ist die einzige sinnvolle IDE unter Windows für kostenlose IDE unter Windows für für.NET. Allein schon deswegen.
Achso Visual Studio Code geht es hier darum. Gut bei Visual Studio Code liegt das ganze ein bisschen anders. Das ist einfach ein sehr schöner erweiterbare Editor.
Wo vieles drin ist und gut funktioniert und wofür es vieles gibt. Dass das Ding eine JavaScript Anwendung ist macht es jetzt nicht unbedingt besser, aber es ist die einzige JavaScript Anwendung die ich gern verwende.
Hast du eigentlich immer noch Home Office? Ja, habe ich.
Wie gesagt wir haben heute auch hier ein bisschen Visual Studio Code rumgewurstet. Kann ich empfehlen es gibt auch nicht so wirklich richtig gute Alternativen zu Visual Studio Code wenn es das können soll was Visual Studio Code kann. Ja weil es jetzt keiner sagt Wim. Ich bin ja auch Wim Fan.
Und ich verwende für kleine Edit Sachen auf der Kommandozeile grundsätzlich nur Wim. Aber was erweiterbar Weiterbarkeit angeht.
In den qualitativen Extensions zum Beispiel die ganze Arduino Platform IO Geschichte. Sowas wirst du in Wim nicht sehen. Atom hat nicht so viele Sachen. Atom ist ein bisschen aus der Mode gekommen.
Es gab ja mal vor vor ich sag jetzt mal vor 7 8 Jahren wo dieses ganze JavaScript Editor Sachen losgegangen ist.
Wie ist Code? Ich muss mal kurz gucken wann das ursprünglich rausgekommen ist. 2015 war das nicht früher.
Sagen wir mal vor so sechs sieben Jahren wo diese ganze JavaScript Code Editor Geschichte angefangen hat. Da gab es drei Stück. Da gab es Atom, da gab es Brackets und da gab es Visual Studio Code.
Atom war da von GitHub. Das waren so die ersten die damit angefangen haben. Und Atom haben wir auch Elektronen zu verdanken.
So muss man an der Stelle gerade nochmal sagen. Und danach kam Brackets von Adobe für HTML Live Editing Zeug. Der ist eigentlich auch ganz cool gewesen.
Aber irgendwie haben die da nichts draus gemacht. Ich finde das von allen Editors damals Brackets das meiste Potential hatte für Frontend.
Aber irgendwie haben die da wenig draus gemacht. Also ich kenne der hat zwar viele Sterne wird noch regelmäßig update aber ehrlich gesagt ich persönlich kenne niemand der Brackets verwendet. Ich weiß nicht vielleicht kennt ihr jemand.
So und irgendwann kam Microsoft mit Visual Studio Code und hat es halt besser gemacht.
Was ist das Ascii-Quarium auch als Webseite musst du mal suchen. Jetzt bestimmt. Keine Ahnung ob es das gibt. Gibt es bestimmt. Wenn nicht nimmst du den GIF auf und spielst im Hintergrund.
Ich muss Brackets in Medien Informatik benutzen. Genau das war die Vorschau vor 5-6 Jahren auch schon. Aber irgendwie haben die nichts großartig draus gemacht.
Visual Studio Code hat sich jetzt halt das in der Zeit mit der Zeit so durchgesetzt weil er halt relativ schnell ist für den JavaScript Editor. Also von allen diesen drei Alternativen ist das eindeutig der schlankste in Anführungsstrichen.
Natürlich ist er im Vergleich mit anderen Sachen weder schnell noch braucht er wenig Speicher. Im Vergleich zu anderen Sachen ist es lahm aber wenn es mit Brackets und Atom vergleicht vor allem zur Zeit damals war Visual Studio Code einfach vorne.
Und das Ding hat halt richtig viele gute Extensions da kann man nichts sagen. So Plime Text habe ich früher verwendet so quasi nicht so 2010 oder so rum bevor dieses ganze JavaScript Zeug aufgekommen ist.
Da habe ich aber so eine Mischung aus Vim und so Plime Text verwendet weil ich dachte damals noch man könnte Vim zu einem Allzweck Editor umbauen der alles kann.
Theoretisch geht das, praktisch beißt sich das bei Vim. Irgendwann ist Vim so aufgebläht dass er langsamer ist fast schon als normale anderen Editors dadurch wenn du zu viel Zeug installierst und außerdem beißen sich verschiedene Plugins in Vim.
Das ist halt nicht dafür gedacht 40 Plugins zu installieren. So dann habe ich mal irgendwann angefangen okay nehmen wir halt für andere Sachen ein bisschen so Plime Text. So Plime Text hat einen großen Vorteil das das Ding ist halt sau schnell dafür ist es echt gut.
So Plime hat doch nur einen Plugin Manager.
Allerdings habe ich auch schon ja ich habe schon einige outdated Extensions gesehen. Ich glaube bis heute gibt es beispielsweise kein ordentliches Terminal Plugin für Plime.
Wobei ich weiß nicht wie es mit so Plime 3 ist mittlerweile.
Nee also Vim kriegst du nicht für alles fit gemacht. Es fängt ja allein schon daran an dass wenn du sagen wir mal du willst keine Ahnung du willst.NET in Vim ist für'n Arsch. Zum Beispiel..NET in Vim ist komplett für'n Arsch.
Aber wenn du schon so Sachen unterstützt willst keine Ahnung wenn du willst Besh drin machen willst Pysen drin machen Ruby und keine Ahnung was immer noch.
Noch irgendwie irgendwie standard Go oder so. Allein schon dann wird es eklig das in Vim einzurichten und jedes funktioniert ein bisschen anders.
Jedes ist der Meinung ein bisschen anders bedient werden zu müssen.
Also so eine komplette Allzweckwaffe aus Vim zu machen.
Beißt sich. Ich habe es öfters probiert.
Es gibt auch kein ordentliches Terminal. Das geht also die die Dinge das ist ich verwende das nicht ja.
Aber das ist ok. Das geht ich glaube das ist sogar auf Basis von.
Ich glaube das ist auf der gleichen Basis wie auch die Neo Vim Terminal Implementierung oder.
Das ist.
In a lip.
Ach frag mir nicht wie das Ding heißt.
Ja ist das Ding.
Lip.
Ich dachte die verwenden die gleich unten drunter das Terminal.
Also kommen im Vergleich zu vielen anderen Terminal.
Guck dir mal das Terminal an in den Jetbrains Ding.
Das ist auch nicht schöner.
Ansonsten ist es auf jeden Fall nicht verkehrt weil man ein bisschen Vim kann.
Allein schon aus dem Grund.
Allein schon aus dem Grund weil Vim auf jedem Furz.
Egal wie klein drauf ist.
Ich glaube sogar auf Cisco Switches ist ein Vim drauf.
Und ich glaube sogar auf das muss ich mir jetzt bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher.
Aber ich glaube sogar auf HP Switchen ist ein Vim drauf.
Wie es bei Ubiquiti aussieht weiß ich nicht habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert.
Könnte ich eigentlich mal ausprobieren.
Mikrotik hat ziemlich sicher auch einen Vim.
Also es ist halt überall da.
Egal wie minimal.
Einen Vim hast du überall drauf.
Sind die im Chat jetzt gerade für Diskussionen am Start.
Leute ihr müsst mal auf eine Sache klar kommen.
Es gibt selten das beste Tool überhaupt.
Es gibt viele Tools die taugen was in der jeweiligen richtigen Situation.
Das heißt es hat eigentlich überhaupt keinen Sinn zu sagen ich verwende nur Vim.
Ich verwende nur Visual Studio Code.
Ich verwende nur Visual Studio.
Ich verwende nur Emacs.
Ich verwende nur was.
Man muss einfach gucken was man machen will und dann das richtige Tool dafür nehmen.
Es hat überhaupt keinen Sinn sich auf irgendwas großartig zu versteifen.
Das habe ich mit der Zeit auch lernen müssen.
Stift und Zettel kann auch durchaus die beste Lösung sein.
Andere Route Empfehlungen außer Mikrotik.
Mikrotik macht mit FSP und PPOI Probleme.
Oh ok.
Echt.
Der Router muss SFP haben und sollte ein Gigabit zwischen VLANs routen können.
Ok komisch das Mikrotik da probieren.
Ähm kenne ich keinen.
Mikrotik ist immer so meine Empfehlung für.
Ich habe aber auch über eine Mikrotik Router ehrlich gesagt noch nie PPOI Einwahl gemacht.
Und auch noch nie da irgendeinen Providergedöns über SFP angeschlossen.
Hab gesehen du nutzt E3 WM.
Für was brauchst du dann noch TMAX?
Schwer zu erklären.
Mir gefällt die Bedienung von TMAX mit der Tastatur besser als mit dem Window Manager.
Zumal ich halt auf dem Remote System auf TMAX verwende.
Also quasi das erste was ich mache wenn ich mich auf irgendeine Server einloge und weiß
dass ich da mehr als 2 Minuten zu tun habe mache ich die TMAX Session auf.
Ja aber ansonsten ist es eher Geschmackssache würde ich sagen.
Du hast ein paar Vorteile von TMAX zum Beispiel dass du in mehreren Fenstern gleichzeitig
tippen kannst.
Wie ging das ich habe da normalerweise einen Shortcut für on.
Ach du Scheiße.
Ich bin da sogar schon dafür zu blöd das einzuschalten.
Ich bin da zu noob für.
Aber du kannst ich habe da ein fertiges SSH Einlogs Skript was das macht und Shortcuts
normalerweise.
Aber da kannst du beispielsweise in zwei Fenstern.
Wie geht denn das noch mal?
Ah okay na meinetwegen.
So und jetzt kannst du beispielsweise hier in beiden Terminals gleichzeitig tippen.
Das kannst du so mit i3 alleine nicht so einfach machen.
Nur so eine Sache es hat bestimmt noch wenn ich ein bisschen drüber nachdenken würde
andere Vorteile.
Es hat aber auch Nachteile beispielsweise das Copy Paste natürlich nicht so schön.
Aber jetzt habe ich gesyncht.
Kann man auch oft sagen.
Aber was macht EMAX nicht?
Zum Beispiel einen ordentlichen Browser.
Das gibt es nur um 20 Umwege und dann auch nur indem man Webkit irgendwie overlayt was
dann auch bescheuert ist.
Und auch die Erweiterbarkeit von EMAX ist jetzt im Vergleich zu einem VS Code wo jeder
da hergelaufene Noob mit JavaScript was machen kann.
Die ganze E-Lisp Geschichte.
Mal eine andere Hausnummer.
Was ist SFP?
Das ist eine Netzwerkentschnittstelle für SFP Interface.
Das ist für Glasfaserkabel.
Und nicht nur für Glasfaserkabel.
Das ist halt ein Connector.
Da kannst du auch Kupferkabel reinstecken wenn du welche hast mit SFP Connector.
Direct Attached Kabel sind ja Kupfer.
Es gibt dann auch SFP auf normale AR45 Dinger.
Das ist aber was wo man an Router Netzwerk Interfaces hat.
Mir werden gerade 12 Stunden C++ Videos auf YouTube vorgeschlagen.
Ja dann Timbo auf gehts.
Oh beste Musik hört ihr es.
Kölby Gourmet Race Orchester Variante.
Gibt es hier was für Fans Compton Fe...
Sagt mir gar nichts.
Compton ist für mich ein Composite Windermänner Render Ding.
Aber du meinst bestimmt was anderes.
Was ist allerkritig?
Das ist glaube ich ein Terminal.
Also sowas hier wie ihr hier seht.
Bloß dass es glaube ich im Backend OpenGL rendert.
Was jetzt sagt man mal so?
Beim Terminal nicht der ultimative Geschwindigkeitsboost ist.
Weil beim Terminal würde ich mal behaupten.
Als jemand der noch nie einen Terminal programmiert hat.
Das was der intern machen muss.
Also wie jetzt irgendwie Text fließt und wann Zeilenumbruch gemacht wird und sowas.
Braucht wahrscheinlich mehr als das eigentliche Rendern.
Und das eigentliche Rendern passiert ja kaum was.
Ob das durch OpenGL so viel schneller wird weiß nicht.
Wann kommt eigentlich das Rechenzentrum Video?
Oh Gott ja Leute.
Letztens erst mit dem Felix auch drüber geschwätzt.
Dass ich schon ewig hinten dran bin mit dem Rechenzentrums Video.
Aufgenommen haben wir es ja schon.
Compton ist doch out.
Die haben doch jetzt, wer denn noch denkt jetzt, wie heißt das?
Peacom wird der neue Compton Fork.
Peacom.
Ja stimmt.
Das scrollen wird wahrscheinlich wenn man.
Ja wenn man scrollt kann ich mir vorstellen.
Ich kann ja gar nicht scrollen.
Aber das scrollen könnte ich mir tatsächlich vorstellen.
Dass das unter OpenGL basierten Terminal schneller ist.
Braucht es jemand zum Videocutten?
Nee.
Ich brauch jemand der mich motiviert aufzunehmen.
Wegen OpenGL schaffen wir es als einzige ohne Probleme mit 144Hz auf meinem Rechner zu rendern.
Ich habe noch kein anderes Terminal gefunden das das schafft.
Aha.
Also Fische in 144Hz ist auch schon was.
Wir haben das Rechenzentrum Video aufgenommen.
Wir müssen dazu noch was labern.
Wir haben dazu zwar gelabert aber die Aufnahme war so schlecht.
Ach leck es mal wieder das war mit der Unity Media am Start.
Oder wurde auch vorne am Start.
Oder meine Augen.
Das ist eine gute Frage wie viel FPS mein Gnome Terminal schafft.
Ich bin ja normalerweise, mein Name ist ja nicht umsonst Max FPS auf YouTube.
Ich bin ja hohen FPS zahlen nicht abgeneigt.
Aber ich hab mich noch nie gefragt wie viel FPS mein Terminal schafft.
Ich wüsste jetzt auch gar nicht wie ich mir das überhaupt anzeigen lassen kann.
Unter Windows würde ich jetzt das Nvidia Overlay da anmachen.
Und hoffen dass das irgendwie da das Programm unterstützt.
Aber wüsste gar nicht wie ich das unter Linux mache.
Wie kann ich mir unter Linux anzeigen lassen mit wie viel FPS mein Terminal gerendert wird.
Keine Ahnung.
Was für ein Ding.
Ach Vodafone ich kann schon mal richtig lesen.
Stimmt was mit meinem Terminal los.
Warum ist er der 20.04.2018.
Weil Datumsformat, Exzellent Datumsformat.
Weil, oh Gott, Ami Datumsformat hör mal auf.
Das fängt ja schon immer an wenn ich auf Amazon Komma nachgucken muss.
So nach dem Mot ja.
Wie viel wiegt denn so ne Maus und seh dann irgendwie was mit 2,5 oz.
Da könnte nicht jeder normale Mensch das in Gramm hinschreiben.
Naja.
Es laggt ja.
Ich gehe jetzt auch.
Ich gehe jetzt auch klar auf.
Reicht.
Ich habe heute eh keinen Big Brain mehr da irgendwie großartig was zu machen.
Ja gut was soll ich sonst noch machen.
Fällt jetzt grad nix mehr ein.
Übrigens die.
Ich habe es ja schon mal ausprobiert.
Wisst ihr was die schlimmste Einheit überhaupt ist.
Btu pro Stunde.
Das ist.
Da steht bei USVs zum Beispiel drauf.
Btu pro Stunde.
Ausleckt.
Wo da vorne.
Btu pro Stunde.
Das hat was gesagt.
Hotspot mit Handy.
Ja.
Hast du variable Bitrate aktivieren.
Warum sollte ich.
Ich habe nicht mal.
Nicht mal richtig Echter.
Hi.
Was ist eigentlich Web Application.
11.
Die du immer streamst.
Ja hier mein.
Mein E-Mode ein Pläne Ding ist das.
Das ist Web Application 11.
Ihr wisst doch dass ich wahnsinnig gut drin bin die Sachen zu benennen.
Das ist das das Meme Board.
Was sogar animierte Gifts und Audio kann.
So.
Ich habe keine Ahnung was schon machen soll.
Fällt jetzt echt nichts ein.
Ich wollte bloß noch sagen dass Btu pro Stunde ein absolut kacke Einheit ist.
Das ist die Menge an Energie die man braucht.
Um ein britisches Pfund Wasser um ein Grad Fahrenheit zu erwärmen.
Alles klar oder.
So kann man schon ein Hosten.
Wo ist der Hoste.
Irgendwie keiner da das brauchen wird von denen den ich Follower.
Naja gut hast du schon mal den Wumpl ausgeholt.
Das wäre es jetzt wenn ich mich selbst haus da habe ich dann auf einmal 300 Zuschauer doppelte.
Spiel werden Ring 0 Kacke.
Ihr wisst doch Leute das Genie überblickt das Chaos.
Quick Masse.
Gut.
So soll ich mein Outro noch spielen.
So.